Sweet jesus.
Fuck yeah.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast.
This is getting boring saying this way.
Every time they listen to what I like
most about this podcast is it has no
professionalism to it whatsoever.
So when I have to say the
same shit over and over again,
I feel like I'm being a
professional and I feel like, uh,
I'm not doing myself a service. It's
nonsense. You know what the fuck it is?
We're sponsored. How do we pay the
bills? Okay, how do I employ Brian?
We have to get money. This is where
we get it. We get it from brain pills,
Alpha brain. What does Alpha
brain, what does Alpha brain,
it's cognitive enhancing
supplement. It is a, uh,
a supplement that has a bunch of
the very best nutrients to support
neurochemistry. And the
idea is that, you know,
your body essentially runs on nutrients.
It's what you need to have
everything functioning optimally,
but you can adjust those levels and add
things and you can get benefits from it.
And Alpha brain to me
is, uh, I, I am fucking,
I'm lost without it. If
I don't have it, I've,
I really do kind of freak out and people
think that I've had people say that
it's a placebo effect and
I say you're fucking crazy.
Cause it gives me these most incredibly
vivid dreams that I never used to have
before. And you know, I think
everybody's different. I don't know.
I don't know how sensitive you are
to your body, but I'm very sensitive.
I'm very sensitive to what's working,
what's not working,
how I feel when I take fish oil,
how I feel when I don't take fish oil,
my body to Joe. I am sensitive. I'm
trying to be sensitive to your soul.
Brian tried to be sensitive to as an
essence realize that were sponsored by a
pharmaceutical company.
Well it's not a pharmaceutical comp
kind of their vitamins for your mind.
Vitamins for your dumb.
Well it is kind of crazy because we also
sell kettle bells and battle ropes and
uh, you're blending it sounds
like that, right? Yeah.
You're building on fucking army for
some reasons and I'm just trying to
strengthen up men. All right. Strengthen
your mind and your fucking body.
And that's what on it's all about what is,
I take Alpha brain every fucking day.
I definitely take it before every podcast.
In fact,
they usually do it in the middle of the
podcast, which is why I'm at my best.
About an hour or so. Anne, what do you
got over there? I got only new mood.
I don't want to take new meter.
And now you've got any of that Alpha brain
retarded.
I was like the worst commercial
for Alpha brain over.
I've been hanging out in Ohio. That's why,
oh, the drain due again. Those vampires,
they got ahold of the courts. We
have um, this new shit that's in,
it's called hemp force and uh,
all the information on any of these things
that I don't want to go too in depth
because people can play in it. These,
these commercials take too long.
What we're trying to do it on it is
sell you the very best shit possible.
As cheap as we can,
and to make it as easy as possible.
So we have a 100% money back guarantee
on your first order of 30 vitamins,
30 pills.
It's Alpha brain or new
mood,
which is a five HTP and l tryptofan
supplement that actually boosts your mood.
It actually boosts your serotonin levels.
And these are all this is,
there's a lot of science behind this
stuff, but it's very controversial.
So if you're interested
at all in nootropics,
I suggest that you Google the word new
tropics and just read on the pros and
cons. But to me vitamins are a
very important part of my life.
I think supplementing has
made me a healthier person
with a body that functions
better period.
Um,
we also have these kettle bells and
battle ropes that are in and I've talked
about them Ad Nauseum,
but the new news is I will definitely be
doing a kettle bell DVD with the Great
Steve Maxwell's mate.
Yeah, we uh, we went,
we did some emails back and forth and uh,
Steve is totally down.
So we're going to, we're
going to do, he's going to,
what are we going to do is I'm going to
have Steve put me through like one of
his brutal workouts and people at home
will be able to do it along with them and
I, I'm, I'm trying to, I'm trying to do
it for too because people, first of all,
people keep asking me to do
one of these and second of all,
because I think people could
really benefit from kettle bells.
I think it's a more interesting way to
work out. It feels more satisfying to me.
It's fucking harder.
Like when I see someone like just
doing bicep curls now I'm like,
you silly bitch. Like
that's nonsense. Like it's,
it's too easy to,
to really get like real benefits that you,
you see when you roll,
when you do Jujitsu,
I feel like you have to do
something really difficult.
You have to do either power lifting,
you have to do cleans and presses,
you have to do squats,
you have to do dead lifts.
If you want to like really get a benefit,
you have to do that.
Or you got to do something
like kettle bells.
And what I like about kettle bells is you,
you got it.
You develop amazing core strength
because you're essentially balancing this
fucking cannon ball and moving it
around and it makes your body work
intelligently as one unit.
And I think you using your body to lift
weights as one unit instead of isolating
areas to me,
shows the best benefits athletically.
So all that shit we sell and on at.com,
um, the vitamins, what
video you're making,
Jim kills me and wants to
know if you be aware, GSP,
I shorts and shorts at GSB.
Where's doesn't really tight
ones that he wants to know.
If you would go do it for
him. Okay, I will do that for
him. I still love him. Um,
anyway, uh, go to [inaudible]
dot com use the code. Any Rogan,
save 10% off any of the supplements. Um,
and, uh, that's including the hemp force.
So you go check it out on a.com o.
N n I t.
And we also want to thank Alienware
for providing us with these super dope
computers.
And I'm now using alien,
whereas the computer that I used
to watch youtube videos and stuff,
so there it's going to be a lot of
new shenanigans flow. Excellent.
We'll get to see pop up screens.
The computers are awesome,
but windows can suck it. How
about that? How about that?
We need to figure out a way to port these
bitches over to Mac. Ooh, wait a minute.
Fanboys all across the world just went,
what the fuck man. I've been playing,
I've been playing a future sponsor,
uh, on the, uh, like, yeah.
I don't know if I can talk about it,
but it's
pretty cool. You don't know if you can
talk about it. I remember the, the gay,
the IPAD a game. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. We'll, we'll, we'll soon. Yeah,
you've been previewing it and we are,
we will soon be sponsored by
a new game company. Um, uh,
that's making a really bad ass iPad games.
Yeah.
And I've been using my iPad a lot
because of this game, which is,
it's kind of weird. It's turned into a
game boy almost. Yeah. Almost Twitter.
Well this, that should be
finalized real shown. All right.
So let's roll the podcast Rep.
We got a lot of shit to talk about.
A lot of shit.
Oh,
pitch out Rogan experience
Joe Rogan podcast all day.
Ladies and gentlemen, we are joined by
congressional candidate David Seaman.
That sounds so, that sounds so official,
dude. I know. It feels kind of ridiculous.
I was at lunch that day with a friend
of mine if we check this and uh,
we were talking about it,
it just sounds so ridiculous to talk
about like your supporters and campaigning
and all this. But uh, it's cool in a way,
cause I used to be the guy who had just
watched TV and be so angry that all of
these dumb asses had been in for 20
years and her legislative terrible stuff.
So I've just read articles about
it and do youtube videos about it.
And then a number of things happened and
I actually had an opportunity to run.
So why not? Why not jump in instead of
just being on the sidelines? Yep. Wow.
That's, did you feel compelled?
Do you feel like a calling
me? How old are you? I,
I'm a, I'm in my mid twenties.
You, you don't want to say I'm 26.
Why didn't you want to say uh,
cause mid twenties more people
can connect with that than 26
we just ruined your entire campaign
over buddy. I'm just kidding.
I don't know. There's normally,
here's why I answered that way.
Normally it's a girl who
asked me how old I am.
And so you can go for like 10
minutes on the guessing game.
Oh and you liked that? I liked
that. So you treat me like a chick.
Well I dare you sir.
How dare you run your shenanigans my way
dude,
I respect you.
If you're still running around with a
last name like semen and being a young man
that had to be brutal. What the fuck was
high school? Like? High school was cool.
It was middle school is bad.
Cause in high school people were like,
okay there were over it. Yeah.
Like in middle school though,
you take the science class where you
first learned about like that that happens
and people just go wild.
They love it. That's it.
It was kind of tempered by there's this
guy in my same class with the last name
either Butkus or but Lik I think it
was but lik so like semen was almost a
little too. It was a little too
obscure for people to grasp but like,
but like you could just
jump on that and you could,
you could really believe that kid.
It's funny how weird noises with your
mouth like have a different effect on
people. Totally. You know, or curse curse
words. Like why is something a curse word?
It's just something coming out
of your mouth. It's, it's almost,
to me it's like that's
the beginnings of all
the beginning of the vault ignorance
is this idea that we have bad words.
It's like, it's almost like
if you can convince people,
like if everybody agrees
that there's bad words,
we all agree there's words you
should never say in certain company.
If you do that, that's a step step
one on the way to be full of shit.
And that, you know, it's weird that
we still accept that. It's so silly.
It's the, those words are
important. If people don't use them,
they're not as fun to talk
to. You know? I don't know.
A single person that never swears that's
as legitimately fun to talk to is my
friends who swear all the time.
If you don't swear it all,
there's something a little
bit wrong with you. Yeah. Uh,
cause it's just,
it's not the way people speak.
It's stupid. It's, it's,
it's you by not using it.
It's stupid because sometimes it's the
fucking word to use. Stop right there.
It was extra fucking, you know, you're
my mom. There's something wrong with her.
Cause she, I, I'll say shit. And
she was like, Bryan was like,
what sucks by your mom's religious though,
Dude.
That's where things could get odd.
Right. Um, in running for Congress,
is that important? Do you have to bring
up religion? Is it, do you feel like, uh,
you need people on your team?
Uh, well, I mean,
I have a lot of republican and a lot of
democratic supporters and obviously a
lot of independence
and libertarian minded,
but they're not supporting me because
of what I believe metaphysically,
whatever that may be.
There were supporting me just because
I want to protect the constitution and
defend the bill of rights. And for
most people, that's enough right there.
And if you believe in those things,
you know that my personal beliefs are
kind of irrelevant as long as I'm not a
member of the League of shadows or
something, you know, and like, yeah,
as long as your religion
isn't harmful to anybody,
it doesn't matter if you're an atheist
or if you're a skeptic or secular or,
you know, extremely. Uh, what's
the word? Extremely devout.
That shouldn't really matter when you're
representing your, your, uh, district.
Yeah, I couldn't agree more
and I, you know, I really,
I've been callous about people's ideas
in the past and made fun of silly
religions.
But the reality is some of the nicest
people I know are religious people. I,
I have a friend who's a Mormon, is like
one of the nicest guys on earth. This,
I now have a frozen
Scientologists. Oh, I've never seen
met Amine Mormon.
They're like nice to the point
where you're like a little bit upset
and they're really charitable. They're
like, it's a beautiful religion. If you,
if you know people that are Mormons and
you see like how much they help each
other when there's like a, if there's
any sort of a crisis or one family has,
how much they chip in, it's a beautiful
community. Even if it's based on nonsense.
It's a,
it's a beautiful community,
but you should be able to do whatever
the fuck you want as long as you're nice.
You know, if that, I like
that guy's my friend.
I mean he believes all
kinds of wacky shit.
They wa they used to wear a special
underwear, the whole fucking deal.
But he's my friend. He's a nice guy. I
don't need him to believe everything.
I believe.
I just need to be able to interact with
him and know that he's got my interest
and his interests and
everybody's interests at heart.
He's not just trying to fuck
the whole thing up for himself.
Yeah, well I mean personal beliefs. Uh,
once you start telling somebody that they
can believe in what they can't believe
in terms of religion, you're
jumping a huge jumping. It's, yeah,
it's a very slippery slope.
It's so when we,
you know,
I think the idea is we should be as
honest as possible about everything about
it. You know, all your own
personal beliefs and religion.
We should all be as honest as possible.
And I think we would come
to like a remarkable middle
ground if we took away all
the ideology. I think we
would come to, if we all,
if we all got together
for the whole world,
could speak one language and we
sat down and talked about religion,
I think we could,
we would form a remarkably similar
opinions if we're really honest about what
the fuck happens when you die and
about who has created this earth.
It's a massive mystery.
Well that, that's the, uh, I'm definitely
not religious, but people have asked me,
uh, somebody's online on Google
plus actually asked me, he was like,
do you believe in God this the deal
breaker for me it was this atheist. So,
and first of all he was,
he was,
he was posting a comment on a thread
that had nothing to do with that.
I was writing something about
censorship or like Internet censorship.
And this is question totally like
hijacking what we're talking about,
but I wanted to answer him and I said,
you know,
I believe in a higher power because I
really don't want to believe that we're
the most advanced thing in the universe.
Like this iPhone over there is the,
the most high tech incredible thing
invented in the whole universe.
I just don't believe that.
And I don't believe that we're necessarily
the highest level of intelligence out
there. I don't, you know, and
if you look at where we are now,
a atheist want you to believe that we
came from kind of like toxic sludge
billions of years ago,
washing up on the shore and it kind of
pre oxygenated earth or whatever the
details are. And I'd like to think
that there's more to life than that.
I really would.
Well, uh, I would like to
too. I don't want to, you
don't want, you don't want to,
you want to think this is it.
This is the fucking floor it and
see where it crashes. Absolutely.
You know,
I think a lot of us would like to think
there's something out there that's a,
that's smarter than us.
I think the real issue is ego is that
the human ego is aware of itself.
And I think when a person
is aware of themselves,
when you start thinking of yourself
and you want to keep yourself alive,
you start looking at yourself like
very selfishly and an objectively.
You start looking at yourself like
you're super, super fucking important.
You know?
I think if we,
if we could get past that and you looked
at life and intelligence, you would say,
well, why does it have to be coming out
of the mouth of some thing that can move
around? Why am I assuming that
that's the only intelligence?
How do I not know that there's
not intelligence and stars?
How do I not know that
there's intent there?
There could be hyper intelligence
all around us. We're just,
we're not capable of
hearing it's frequency.
We're not capable of
communicating with it.
Why does this bag of blood and cells and
nerve endings and electrical impulses,
why does this make noise with its mouth
and change the world? Why does it,
why the fuck does that happen? Well,
who knows? It doesn't make any sense.
How do you,
how do you not know that there is not
an intelligence to everything around us
all the time.
It's just imperceptible to us and
they're starting to figure this out with
plants.
They're starting to figure out that
plants have some sort of rudimentary or a
unknown rather,
I'm going shouldn't say rudimentary.
You might be like really complicated
method of communicating with each other.
It's fucking, I'm actually,
I've actually ready
when one of the, one of the
trees gets cut down. Hey, send a,
like a chemical signal through
the roots. The other trees. Yeah.
And like warn them or something.
Nothing really matters cause you're
a tree and you can't go anywhere.
But they still, they send out the warning
signal, you know? And uh, there's,
I don't know if this has
been debunked or not,
but somebody put out a book a while ago
that my aunt was really into and it was
like if you're in a room with the plant
and you have positive emotions of like,
I love this plant, it fares better
than a plant where you're like,
I need it for this damn thing out.
Yeah. They, yeah, I think that's real.
I don't even think we might
have to Snopes that one. Nope.
It cause Snopes tends to be
pretty honest about that shit.
Although there do seem
a little pessimistic.
You're saying Snopes once in a while. I
was on the rag. I Dunno. Do you think so?
Yeah.
Question Snoop Bees,
butthole.
Do Plants do plants? Do you
plants care? Do you plan
a positive emotion plant?
Yeah. Positive. Yeah.
Positive singing to plants,
benefits of Po Positive Planet sex people.
I wonder if he had sex with lance if
they would grow bigger maybe if you just
came on your plant.
Oh yeah.
Sprinkled a little every day on one
communication. I put so many, some
Gatorade once and it looked like a grease,
like twice its size overnight.
What?
I put some come in and I wipe my come off
in with Gatorade and it seemed like it
just expanded really big in the Gatorade.
So I don't know if there's a chemical
reaction between the two, but yeah,
this is a,
I think I was too vague in my search.
People talk to plants. What, what would
you say? It's not people talk positive,
positive energy or energy around plants.
Helping
butthole.
Is that hurricane hitting
Florida right now?
Got It. I got out of there. Uh, they
offered to change my flight for no fee.
Oh, relied. Flew out a day early. Just
because you want to be stuck in that.
Even if there is nothing big
airlines will cancel your flights.
Just out of caution.
You know,
I,
I flew on southwest the other day and I
just wanted to sleep and the whole time
they played games on the intercom and
like, like Trivia Games with everyone,
they're like, now press your
button, that Ding button, you know,
like the help me button.
It seemed totally illegal because like,
what if somebody really needed help,
like a heart attack and there's all these
people dinging and they're like, no,
I'm having a heart attack. You
know, a southwest. I don't,
I don't like those games.
Like, uh, I remember one time,
I don't want to like single out and
say it was definitely southwest cause I
don't, I don't wanna be sued. Right. But
I'm like 99% sure it was southwest. Yeah,
me too.
I'm 99.9 the flight attendant was making
some kind of lame joke about like I
hope like hopefully we'll land. Right.
And I was like, that's like for me,
it doesn't matter cause
you fly enough times,
you know that the odds are in your favor.
Right.
But every once in a while to get that
person who's flying for the first time.
Right. And that probably freaks
the hell out of that person.
Yeah. You almost swore and, and you
know, backed off it perfectly though.
This is what one of the stewardess said,
I'm trying to sleep and they're
screaming on Entercom the whole flight.
I want to kill people. Like,
like, like she says, all right,
now take your seatbelt and
cross your lips. Oh, I'm in
hips and I'm thinking like,
did she just meet Pussy lips cause she
made like the motion like cross your belt
over your,
she probably used to be a stripper name.
She was a flood trying to sleep
America. I was pretty impressed with, uh,
I don't know how they're
able to do this legally,
but everybody was young and
had a good attitude. Yeah.
And that's like my
euphemism for hot women. Uh,
and there are other airlines like because
of unions and stuff, they're just,
they have serious attitude.
They hate their job and they're old.
They've been there for like 30 years.
Yeah.
And or theirs, their standup comics
that never made it. And the other,
they're trying to material out
because they have a captive audience.
Who are you gonna do?
Like jump out?
Joey and I had a guy recently in flying
into Denver that has like a whole
routine. They're like, how to let go.
He was doing stand up. I was like,
as a standup, I know when someone's doing
standup, like he was doing stand up,
he had like a whole routine that it would
do like a bunch of one liners about,
uh, about travel. It was so silly.
There's this one pilot that sings
every time he takes off and lands.
It's a song that should definitely be
legal cause you use using the like using
up the airwaves. I know what
I'm saying. It's ridiculous.
Do you have it? It's just so gross.
Like who are you? This is my plane.
I'm not a pilot.
Slaps the waitress on it.
Her ass was it flight attendant on
her ass as he moves into the cockpit,
gives his buddy knuckles.
I'm going sing to these people.
They need to hear my voice and loop brain.
It was also so cold and I was like can I
please have a blanket? And they're like,
we don't have blankets.
And I'm like all right.
So I had to make one of those like things
where you take your arms and put it
inside your shirt and then just like
make a cocoon and like bundle up in a
corner because it was so freezing on
the plane. Why they're doing this.
How healthy could it be being a pilot
you just flying up and lasted by
radiation. Plastic by radiation
in front of like a window.
Yeah. It makes me want to play
trivia games or the inner comments.
He knows how much radiation is involved
in, in plane flight. Do you know? Uh,
I heard something like a cross country
is like the equivalent of a chest x ray
or something. It's not,
it's not, it's nothing.
It's just the fact if you're flying
every single day as they do it,
my dad up and uh,
radiation is not as bad for you as people
make it out to be like the Fukushima
style stuff is definitely really
bad for you. But in terms of like,
just low ambient doses,
you're getting radiation
just walking outside.
I make sure everything I read somewhere
like in a kitchen with a marble top
that's giving off radiation. Yeah.
Isn't that crazy? Yeah. Yeah.
I was watching some documentary on TV
where they were talking about dinosaur
bones.
Some of them being radioactive.
They need a coat them with lead paint to
try to reduce the amount of radioactive
energy that came off. I don't know.
Right. It's horse shit or not. It sounds,
it sounds silly, but it actually makes
sense if the dinosaurs died, you know,
from some sort of a, um, uh, a
meteor impact or something like that,
that there was some mean 6,000
and 6,000 years ago, right? Yeah.
How long has a half life for
that stuff? They said, no,
I'm saying the dinosaurs 6,000 years ago,
it was at least 6,060 6,000 or more.
How do you deal with that question?
Is Anybody ever, for folks who don't
know what the fuck we're talking about,
serious fundamentalists believed
that the earth is 6,000 years old?
I think the way I'd answer is I'd be like,
I definitely believe there were dinosaurs
on the planet 6,000 or more years ago.
I don't believe they're
tricked by the devil.
I don't believe like dinosaur fossils
are there to confuse us and like question
our faith. I think they're there
because their dinosaur fossils,
Bill Hicks had a great joke about that.
It doesn't make you,
it doesn't it bother you.
The God might be fucking with you.
God might be fucking with your head.
That's such a great bit about God burying
dinosaur bones and Giggling, like,
figure this out.
Now he's questioning your faith.
That's what's all that's hilarious.
That is one of the most beautiful
ways to shut down new ideas.
It's Satan questioning
your faith. Yeah. Yeah.
You can't let that 6,000 year thank
go. Okay. We know more now period.
You can't trust what was in a book that
was written by people who, you know,
we're deciphering it from several other
different languages. Also, by the way,
it didn't immediately go to English.
It had to be translated from Hebrew to
Latin to grid and a lot of shit missing
from that man. Maybe that's 6,000 years
is a figure of speech, you know? Yeah.
I wondered about that. Like you look
at a Wikipedia entry and here we have,
we have digital content where you
transfer something and it's 100%, uh,
intact back then.
You're just doing it by hand and
like you have other issues going on.
Maybe you get hit with plague and shit.
Fuck the editors get wiped out.
But like whenever you copy
something from book to book,
they're going to be big changes. Just
that of like it's what happens, accidents,
you know? Yeah, yeah. So true.
There's no way you can spread information
on the back of animal hides for a
thousand years and have
that shit come out perfect.
It's kind of let that 6,000
year thing go. Well, it's wild.
It just like for 400 years ago,
people really thought that a or the,
I don't know if they've thought this,
they were told that the
earth was the center of the
universe. Yeah. And you know,
these people were not any
dumber than we are today.
Like biologically the same brain and
people were doing smart stuff back then,
but they had to like buy in
at this collective bullshit.
Like, Oh yeah. Uh, it is,
we're definitely the center of the
university even though we know that that's
not the case.
And back then if you said something,
if you came out with new information
that showed that the current
model was completely false,
they will put you in jail or kill.
You just accept it.
You weren't allowed to just
come out and say, hey man,
I think that we're spinning around
it and it's one of a bunch of them.
Yeah. We weren't allowed to say
that. They were like when gout,
there wasn't Galileo was
put under house arrest and
yeah, he was under house arrest. I
mean it was considered heresy, right?
Yeah. You new information. Is
he considered like say tannic?
They wanted to, what's really
exciting if you, I mean ridiculous.
Rather if you stop and think about that,
like they just won the block
down information so bad
that if you had some new
stuff they wouldn't even consider it.
It was the work of the devil.
They had it locked down.
They know exactly what was up.
That kind of confidence is so ridiculous.
Well, it might've been lack
of confidence actually,
because if you acknowledge
that, okay, you guys are right,
the earth is just this insignificant
thing in a much bigger picture,
then maybe people go, what about the pope?
Do we still have to pay homage to them?
Or could that be a typo? Also,
you know, uh, that's awesome.
One of the most ridiculous things
ever that like foreign dignitaries and
presidents and prime ministers,
they have to sit down and
meet with the fucking pope.
They have to sit down and meet with this
cult leader who's dressed like a wizard
in a star wars episode.
I mean,
it's the most ridiculous idea ever that
this guy should still be dressing like
this and 2012 and we should
still pretend that he's holy.
We should still pretend that he's got
the Willy Wonka golden ticket to Jesus's
fucking factory fuck house.
It's unbelievable, man.
It's unbelievable that that still works.
That kind of stuff is preposterous.
That kind of stuff is,
that's mind boggling.
It's not whether or not there's a god,
it's not whether or not, you know,
the idea of higher power exists.
Of course it does.
He would be crazy to think that some
higher intelligent might be at the end of
all this, why not? Who we are.
Look how much change we enact on our
environment and we do it thoughtfully.
We do it whether it's reasonable or not,
we're thinking about it while
we're doing it. And when,
when even when you throw
garbage in the ocean,
you're thinking about when you do that,
why wouldn't we assume that there's some
sort of an intelligence to galaxies?
Why wouldn't we assume that? You know,
just cause it can't talk English.
That's so arrogant to me.
I,
it's crazy to think that we're the only
intelligence just because we can clearly
communicate with each other but
can't communicate with other things.
Yeah. That's like, uh, how they test for
intelligence in schools at the sat test.
So you get somebody who's
good at memorizing facts
and filling out bubbles and
it doesn't count it off of that person
who's like truly a genius at painting or
designing websites or doing things that
are ultimately like much more lucrative
than filling out a bubble test me.
Well Rosie. Yeah. Brian is
a good example. I mean you,
you did say that as a Chug,
but you are a good example.
Like you're great at what you do.
I fucking hate math.
Imagine if you had to do something else.
What if you had to be a lawnmower guy?
And what if you got to be a guy who mows
lawns? How good would you be at that?
He would fucking suck at that.
What does some people, you know,
certain things have no appeal to them.
They have no desire to do it for other
people. Other people love mowing lawns.
Okay? Some, I know dudes who are landscape
artists, they're fucking artists, man.
They put together like the put the plants
in the right place and they range the
flowers perfectly, cut everything. And
it creates this really nice aesthetic.
Like when a guy does it, your,
your front lawn and you know,
if there's a guy across the street from
my house who has like little gnomes and
shit, puts all these little
things in front of me,
he's creating light little work of art
out there that guys compelled to do that.
And Man, everybody's compelled
to do different shit.
The real problem is that
we don't recognize that.
We're always trying to push people
into areas where they're not compelled.
You know, we're trying to tell people,
you can't be a professional skateboarder.
There's no money in that.
Then you go, what the fuck
is Tony Hawk? Who's that guy?
Why is that guy's, that
guy's fucking huge. Okay,
how come he don't tell me there's
no money in it? There's money in it.
Just stop telling me what to do.
I'm going to do this.
I'm going to try to do that.
Well, people have such a
weird attitude. Like, uh,
I told people I was coming out here, do
your show and to do a couple of meetings.
And uh, they're like, so if somebody's
paying you to go out there and I'm like,
are you serious? Like I'm going to
be in front of millions of people.
And I'm like, that's the first
question in your mind is going to be,
am I being paid to come out? You know?
And people really think like that.
Like you asked them to do something
and it's like, well, is this on the,
is this on the payroll? You know, and
you're like, just fucking do it. You know,
like if it's something important,
you should do it.
Like there are a lot of people who they
want to be in a cubicle and get paid on
a time schedule.
That's all they want.
And if they encounter somebody who's
not on that same, that same, uh,
thought process of, I wonder what my
annual salary this year is going to be,
then they're confused.
Like, wait a second,
why aren't you maximizing year
available work hours? You know?
Yeah. That's, we want to know that
we have a certain amount of money
coming in every month. Yeah.
I mean that, that's normal.
That's just like not wanting to starve.
Yeah. But then there are people who, uh,
took anything that's coming out of a
place of passion or a place of civic duty.
It's like, what does that all about?
You know, like, uh, the TSA for example,
whenever I rant about them on Twitter
or on one of my articles on business
insider, I get a couple of people who
always say they're just doing their jobs,
leave them alone. I'm like, that's,
that's the justification given for some
of the most evil stuff that's been done
on this planet.
We're just doing our jobs.
Find a job that doesn't violate people's
constitutional rights. You know,
find a job where you can go home at
night and not be like embarrassed about
you're doing all day and for the money
they're making, whatever they're making,
it's not enough to just totally
infringe on other people's basic rights.
And I feel that way.
Like it's not all about the money.
It has to be the money and doing
something that you're okay with.
I don't think, I don't, first of all, um,
I don't think it's the fault of the Tsa.
I think first of all,
that's an incredibly difficult
job. Whenever you're trying
to search people shit,
when they're on their way somewhere,
that's a difficult job because what if
someone does get through with a bomb when,
if someone does get through some shit
that can it like the inside of the plane
on fire we got,
he gets a real problem and
we live in a fucked up time.
We really do.
We do live in a fucked up time,
but these people that are working there,
man, they're just people with jobs.
The people that are running the whole
thing must be responsible. Yeah. Yeah.
Whenever, whenever you have a problem
with somebody, it's the people at the top.
You, you give people a job like that. Like
you gotta make sure nobody has a bomb.
Like all right, you know,
like sir, listen to me sir.
Like people don't want to listen to you.
It's a,
people naturally get a little bit douchey.
Everybody you meet is NOI
to meet you all day long.
There are no aid to be in front of
you that annoyed you just getting this
fucking cancer ray from them all day long.
So I think we need to figure out a way,
first of all,
to make it like way less
intrusive on people. Definitely.
Well it's more realistic to like old
people and babies and shit really.
Is this baby a terrorist? Yeah.
Quiet. You know, it's one of the only,
for a lot of people it's one of the
only times where you meet the federal
government face to face, you know,
representative of the federal government.
And it's normally not a
pleasant encounter. Like you
said, they're annoyed. Yeah.
You're either annoyed or scared. Uh,
it could be an awesome experience.
It could be like, wow, the government is
looking out for me. This is efficient.
This is a decent use of tax dollars.
But instead I get the opposite feeling.
I'm discussed that every time
I go through with that. Well,
it's the same with tourists.
Like people come to the U S and they don't
want to come back because if you're a
visitor,
you get treated even worse.
If you're like automatically you get
the Kiefer Sutherland treatment and like
they think you're a threat until
you prove otherwise. Yeah. We're,
we're a nation of cons.
I don't think I'm watching it. I'm not
going to campaign on that. Don't do it.
It wouldn't help. But it's, it's, it's
so frustrating. It's really frustrating.
We will stop and think about it. Could
you imagine the baby's war terrorist?
Oh Gosh. It's terrible. First,
the first terrible thing is that we
have to worry about someone pulling, uh,
you know, a stunt like
that, that dude did, uh,
when to tried to light his underwear
on fire. What is he trying to do?
Lighter shoes on fire from that guy on.
Everybody had to take their shoes off.
The thing with al Qaeda is they really
don't seem to try the same thing multiple
times.
Like nine 11 happened.
If we're going to just stick with the
official story and not delve into crazy
alternative possibilities,
which are definitely possibilities based
on the research. I've done. But uh,
if you're going with the official story,
uh,
this took them years to plan out and it
works. Not because they were geniuses.
It works because it's like running up
to the biggest kid on the playground and
just unexpectedly kicking him in the nuts.
Like,
that's going to work because
he's not expecting it. You know,
it's not going to work a
second time or third time.
But they did something that was totally
unexpected and that's why it worked.
Not because they were brilliant
masterminds and then they try completely
different, you know, the underwear
bomb or the a shoe bomb and that's it.
Next time we shouldn't even be
looking at airports. Honestly,
the next threat is going to be something,
whatever it is,
I would put my money up being something
completely different from that.
Yeah. And then the idea is that the
more rights they take away from us,
the less likely that is to happen.
But it's still real bad guys.
Real bad.
Whether or not something's going
to happen is that illegal legal,
the pet on the next year.
Crazy. A crepe. Creepy pastor.
You can't do that. Man, I can't bet on
shit. Although there are like in London,
there's that bedding house where you
can bet on anything and he'd be like,
what are the odds that Madonna,
we'll get like an STD in the next 18
months and there's an, or whatever it is,
there's a wager on it in England and
help do that kind of stuff like that.
Those crazy bets.
Good idea. I'm sure he would. Yeah. Stan
herb and I, by the way, are doing a,
uh, end of the year, um,
December 21st end of the world,
Mayan calendar,
apocalypse show in Hollywood.
We're going to do it at the Wiltern
theater in Hollywood. It's going to be me,
Joey Diaz, Stan hope and honey honey.
Wow. That's going to be so fucking great.
Yeah, we're working it all out now, but
it'll be at the Wiltern December 21st.
I don't think tickets are not on sale yet,
but it's going to be fucking crazy. Oh.
And we're at the ice house this
weekend. We had to cancel, um,
this show at Mandalay Bay because of the
UFC got cancelled the first time ever.
And, uh, so we moved the
show to the ice house.
Friday is 10 o'clock and
Saturday is 10 30, I believe.
Or is it the other way around?
Tenish ice has comedy.com to get tickets
to their greatest club in the world.
This place, it's, it's run by the
nicest people ever. It's in Pasadena.
And the, uh, the way this
place is set up, it's,
it's basically the same club that
was here in the 1960s. It's amazing.
It's like a slice of history and a, and
we love it. So we hear all the time.
So this weekend it'd be
me, Joey, and Ari and, uh,
it will be just like a regular real show,
you know what I'm saying?
Or it's just come on down. So, uh,
David Seaman, I'm sorry. We, we, uh,
we went off track there. No,
you've been a, you've been
off bear for a while, right?
So you're trying to catch up. Yeah. Yeah.
We were in a vacation mode last week.
So you're,
um, you're, you're running for Congress
out of Florida. Yes sir. And when you're,
when you're doing that, what do you have
to do? Like how do you get your word out?
Do you or do you go door to door?
Like how do you let people know?
Do you just put out an internet videos?
Like what's your method of a,
I never leave the apartment now I believe,
you know,
like right now we're actually
trying to build national awareness.
So it does involve a lot of internet
stuff and doing TV shows and local radio
shows and uh, that's the best way to hit
people. Like it makes you sound like,
uh, like you're lazy and
you're like, I just do that.
But I mean we also go out and talk to
actual people and shake hands and all that
stuff. But you do that, you're
exhausted by the end of the day.
You've talked to some crazy,
you've only made a difference.
You've made a difference of like,
now 20 people know who you are.
Versus like somebody who's like, you want
to do a radio show and like, you know,
they call your cell phone and you, you
lie and say it's a land line. Because,
you know,
they call your cell phone,
you talk to some dude for 10
minutes and you're like, okay,
now 10,000 people in this
area know about my campaign.
That's a hell of a lot better than
shaking hands with the crazy people. Yeah.
But you need to do both because you
can't be this disconnected like media
personality. You have to actually
know what you're talking about.
Especially when somebody
hits you with a local issue,
you gotta be right on top of that.
And the best way to know about
that is by talking to people. Yeah,
that's a really good point man.
So it's not either or. It's both.
You know that you gotta be hands on and
you also have to be the online method of
distribution is the new way. I mean
for everything for standup comedy for,
and you still gotta you still
gotta suck up to mainstream media.
Even though I hate them.
I was like,
I mean CNN and Msnbc won't have me.
I don't think they'll have me on,
cause I've trashed them
so many times on Twitter.
But there are a couple of cable networks
that liked me and having me on and
they're like my lifeblood for getting
the word out about this stuff. You know?
What is your main beef with
mainstream news? What is a,
what is the main problem you have with it?
A total lack of a sense of scale.
Like there'll be like we have
controversial, controversial,
new tweets from Justin Bieber after
the break and you're like, you're like,
you're like, this is really Fox News
or this is really MSNBC, you know?
Or like Paul Ryan's budget plan might
affect us in 10 years and you're like,
okay, let's, that's fine for a segment.
But what about covering the massive
protests that are happening around the
country that I have to tune in to on
like some live streams site that somebody
sends me an email and I
see people not much older,
not much younger than me getting
the shit kicked out of them,
especially girls for some reason. I see
a lot of that and this is all happening.
I'm like,
this is incredible.
And you look at the bottom and it's
like 6,000 people watching 7,000 people
watching 8,000 people watching
and you're like, any second,
this is going to be on CNN and
I've done this a million times.
You turn on the TV and you're like,
okay, say something about the protests,
not a single word. And it starts
to creep you out and you're like,
maybe they know about this and they're
just not saying anything because a lot of
people send in tips.
A lot of people tweet CNN and
email CNN and a email producers,
they're like,
I know how to work with TV producers.
If for some reason those handful of
networks just don't want to cover what's
happening in this country.
They don't want to cover a civil unrest.
They don't wanna cover police beating
people and they don't want to cover
anything that Congress has been working
on over the past eight months. Uh,
I've not heard much coverage of
this stuff. Yeah, it's disturbing.
When you find out how
many different places are
experiencing this massive amount
of civil unrest,
it's happening all over the world.
I think they can just control it.
Like if it's not until it's on the
evening news, it's not really a thing.
Like somebody might, you know, post
about it on Twitter or Facebook,
but you're able to, it's not legit.
Yeah. You're able to cognitively be like,
well that's just Chris or that's just
Amy there. They've always been Weirdos,
you know. And then once it's on TV, it's
real because it's this collective thing.
And a, just a quick
shout out, a current TV
and our current TV and rt
America have kicked ass.
They're actually covering this stuff.
They're covering the protests.
They had been covering Nda and uh,
uh,
Sopa and Cisco and all of these crazy
bills that Congress is working on.
They're actually doing what all the TV
networks, uh, used to do. Well, you know,
we can do is all of us can start
paying attention to them and not paying
attention to exactly.
Exactly.
We have to figure out who
the fuck has a Nielsen box
get inside that guy's head and go, listen
man. CNNS ratings are down tremendously.
The down like 50% over the past year.
Really. And it gives her science,
cause people just don't buy it anymore.
They're always going to have that
person out there who wants to watch, uh,
like a political shout
fest, you know? Right.
But there are a lot of people who would
just rather look for news on Twitter or
look for news on Google News.
I mean at least Google News.
Like you type in protest and you see
real articles about what's happening. Uh,
so it's a better way to
get your information.
Do you think what's happening is that
because of the spread of information
through the Internet and we've realized
how they've done business as usual the
whole time,
they have denied attention to a
lot of really important things,
but we didn't have any other
way to get the information out.
Like if there's something
happening in the Congo,
like I didn't know anything about
Liberia until I watched the vice guide to
Liberia and I was like,
Holy Shit.
Like what a crazy part of the world.
This is.
Why didn't I get that from any
other sources as well, you know? No,
their sources had it on and
it was not on CNN. It wasn't,
I mean they wouldn't air a show like that.
It's almost like in in
them having the power,
they ultimately became corrupt.
Even if you have the,
your idea is that you want to,
you know,
do some sort of a news thing if
you're not monitored, if no one, no.
Like in the day back now,
everything is so transparent.
But back then you weren't monitored.
You put on whatever you wanted to put on.
Whenever the government told you to put
on whatever deals he had made the put on.
I think you're partially right.
I think a part of the reason why we feel
like there's so much bad stuff going on
today is that we have access to it.
And back then you had three,
three TV networks,
not even cable.
You just said that the three networks
and they told you what you were supposed
to be worried about and that was it.
Alice, you're going gonna get information,
the newspapers and same thing there.
But I think also there's a big aspect of
it that things really are accelerating.
And getting worse.
Some of those things they're drafting
and congress are things that a previous
generation would have just said,
hell no.
Like this is like the people in Congress
wouldn't have thought of drafting it
and people hearing about it one way or
another would have not tolerated it well.
We have a much higher tolerance right now
for corruption and for bad legislation
than we used to. Is that because we're
too distracted? What do you think? That's,
that's my guess is we're distracted and
things were still good right now for a
lot of people, like if you can
pay your rent and uh, you know,
you can watch a hundred
channels on online or on cable,
you're constantly entertained and as long
as you're not starving and as long as
you're not bored,
you're not going to go out in the streets
and protests,
losing your right to a trial or losing
any of these things that we've lost over
the past eight months.
And that's with a lot of people don't
realize is national defense authorization
act that got passed, which is what
really is, is an act of treason.
I mean it's, it's, you could think
of no other way to describe it
to be high treason. Like that's
what I'm saying. Like if this,
if in the sixties or the seventies,
uh, if the people found out that, oh,
by the way,
a Kennedy drafted something that
would take away your right to a trial,
allow him, knew, imprison you on
suspicion alone for the rest of your life.
People would be like, what? No way
that we're supposed to trust them.
That they're only going to use
it on people who deserve it.
They're only going to do it on bad
guys. It doesn't happen. Don't,
don't worry about it, Mike. It
doesn't, it's not about you.
We're just worried about terrorists.
We're not going to use to say, oh yeah,
and also that's, that's not the role of
the government the first place. It's like,
it's not,
it's like I'm going to have a,
I'm going to have your girlfriend
and my bed, but don't worry about it.
Nothing's going to
happen. It's like, well,
that's not an option in the
first place. Yeah. You know,
you doing these things is not something
that's constitutional begin with.
So your intentions don't really matter.
It's frightening that
that could ever get past.
It's really frightening and it just
shows you how when people are in power,
when they're in positions of power,
they do everything they possibly can to
hold it and we'll you sense a trend of
this,
what the trend is.
Information is coming in and people are
having much more access to all sorts of
things and ultimately the Internet is
going to represent how people communicate
and how people express anything, whether
it's voting, whether it's decided.
I mean that's how it should be.
It should pretty sure if she'll be,
we should be able to figure out how
to make each human being have a bio
identifiable characteristic.
Whether it's looking in their
eyes are registering their finger.
You everybody should have that shit on
their fucking laptop and we should all be
able to vote online because then
things would be a whole lot different.
That is the future and they don't
have that yet and it's real close.
So these fucking assholes that are running
things are just holding on tooth and
claw.
And the way they're doing that is by
pulling rights away and they're doing it
under the guise of, of helping
us, which is fucking disgusting.
It is. And I have a theory that I've
never said anywhere else before,
but you were talking about how, uh,
you know, they're taking away rights.
People are kind of wising up and
they're no longer tolerating it because
information is getting out. Uh, I
wouldn't stay click my reputation on this,
but my theory is that, uh, it got to
the point with Bush eight years of Bush,
it's where the, they knew that the
people just were not having it anymore.
They're sick of funding wars.
They're sick of this Patriot Act stuff,
the whole thing. Right. Uh,
and then Obama came along draped and hope
and change and very positive message.
And uh,
people put their support behind them
and thought they were getting something
brand new. And when really he's backed
by the same people who backed Bush,
essentially the same
kinds of interests and a,
so you had a couple of years there
where people let their guard down and
meanwhile the same stuff has been
happening, taking away more rights.
The Patriot Act not stopped being used.
A 300,000 people have been around
300,000 people have been served nsls uh,
and they might be spying on
hundreds of millions of Americans.
I had so much more confidence in us when
I was really young during the Clinton
administration.
I had so much more confidence in what
the government would and wouldn't do to
civilians to its
civilization. I remember, uh,
I remember this girl in my class,
her dad worked on the Hubble
Space Telescope and he
came to our school to talk
about it and like there was a camera crew
there from the TV stations and stuff.
I remember thinking how cool this is.
Like government is funding this crazy
thing that is going to make a difference
in like move us forward. You
know, it's like, this is amazing.
And now I don't feel that
way about a lot of programs.
Like now I'm constantly
being sent articles where
you just kind of a disbelief
like the, you've probably
read about this, the DRP,
the national defense
resources preparedness, uh,
executive order. What is that?
So a reader sent this to me and you
always follow tips regardless of what they
are. I read through this thing, it's
an executive order from Obama and uh,
I was like, this is, this is bullshit.
This must be made up somehow.
But then I went on the White House website
on whitehouse.gov where they have to
publish the executive order is word for
word. I read through it and I was like,
Whoa, this makes no sense. He's claiming
powers that no president should claim.
The ability to,
uh,
nationalize whole companies are
nationalized industries and take personal
property and land and really take in,
do whatever his administration wants.
All they have to do is claim they're
preparing for a national emergency.
There doesn't have to be
proof that there's a national
emergency on the way that
doesn't actually have to be
a national emergency. Uh,
the national emergency can just be him
declaring that there might be one of the
national emergency could be the
threat of terrorist. Yeah, exactly.
It could be just this looming threat
of terrorism and then it's white.
So I'm sorry.
But that's,
that's the scariest thing about
having that sort of an enemy.
You can kind of claim it's everywhere,
right?
Well and the NDA part of the
languages until hostilities end.
So what does that mean?
It's like when,
when there's not a single
violent person on the earth,
whoever commits a crime or
turns to violence against
innocent people, then we'll,
we'll stop detaining
people without a trial.
What is the exact language until
has still yes. Go on. Go on.
Belligerent act.org. I'm not
affiliated with them, but uh,
it's just this one page site does a
great job of breaking down the exact
language until hostilities.
That so creepy. Can you
bring that up and uh, sure.
Read it. Cause they do a good
job of highlighting this.
It again, it's belligerent,
act.org
because there are a lot of people,
when I was covering this stuff with like,
I want to see the exact language,
you don't know what you're talking
about, and I was like, well,
this is based on the [inaudible] analysis
and Amnesty International's analysis
and you know, et Cetera.
They're like, I don't care.
I still want to see the exact language.
Belligerent and that website does
a good job of showing people like,
here are the exact words that
were signed into that affect
you. I don't want to read this
man. I'm going to get depressed.
I can't get a lot of the rich, you
can't spell belligerent. He sleep bitch.
It's two L's.
Oh,
be contained indefinitely without
trial. Wow. It's just so weird.
It makes it legal to incarcerate United
States citizens without recourse to any
form of judicial process. Just that alone.
Yeah. That's crazy. What do you mean?
Why do we have a,
why don't we have a judicial branch
if you're not going to use it?
The idea that you would allow someone
to sign a law that says they can
incarcerate United States citizens
without recourse of any form.
There's nothing you can do.
They can lock you up for the rest of your
life and that's written down somewhere
and we're just,
because it's written down somewhere,
that doesn't mean it's not crazy,
but the fact that they even thought
that they could be able to pass that,
that that would be something that
you could put into law. What,
what life in prisons. Not Enough.
We already have that. You know,
it was there that Martin Luther king
quote talks about how he talks about how
there's a difference between,
uh,
breaking the law and like abiding, I'm
missing it. Messing up his quote entirely.
It basically like, just because
it's a law doesn't make it just,
and just because it's just, it might
not necessarily be the law, you know,
you might be doing something
that's against the law,
but it's the just thing to do.
And at the same time a law might be
profoundly unjust just because somebody
signed a piece of paper,
as you said,
that doesn't mean that we should ruin
thousands of people's lives over it.
It's completely ridiculous and it's the
only reason why it's here is because
this is the old way. This
is the way things were done,
the way things were done,
it was very difficult to change laws
and things were written in fucking stone
and that was what it was.
And people are evolving,
culture's evolving.
Our understanding of our world is changing
and ever moving forward and our laws
should reflect that. And it
shouldn't be the opposite of that if,
if there's a tightening down.
Well,
that to me is a great example of how
there's someone who doesn't get it and
there's someone who doesn't get it, is
the people that are actually running shit,
they have the wrong intentions.
They're not looking at this correctly.
You shouldn't be trying to tighten up.
You should be trying to help all the
things that are fucked up about the world.
That's what we should be
using our resources for,
and there's money in that as well. By
the way, there's jobs in that as well,
by the way.
There's jobs in any direction you take.
I mean the t the TSA is creating jobs.
I'd rather see people employ more,
employ more people over at NASA.
I would like to see that too.
I would like to see that much more than
I would like to see us go into foreign
countries and invade their soil.
But I think what's really scary to me
is that people are allowed to make these
decisions without the will of
the American people behind them.
This is literally drafted behind
closed doors and people had no input.
It's terrifying.
And how did find out about this?
A reader sent me a thing about it
and it was, it was a link to a,
an article that wired had done
back in I think early December.
It might've even been November.
And so I did a youtube video about it.
I did some articles and I felt like
there's no way this thing will actually
become law,
but it's still disturbing.
I have to keep an eye on it and
tell people about it. And then, uh,
Obama Obama came out and
said his administration came
out and so that they were
going to veto it. And then I was like, all
right, good. This is what should happen.
You know, something ridiculous as proposed
and they say, we're not signing this.
And then on New Year's Eve a while,
everybody's out drinking and not
paying attention to these things,
he signed it into law. And then after that
I took some heat for that and he said,
well, I'm not going to use
what I just signed into law.
I'm not going to use that section.
And he issued a signing statement saying
that he wasn't gonna use it. But, uh,
the problem with that is
it's not legally valid.
It's like doing something and then
putting a post it note on somebodies door
saying, sorry about that. Like the
signing statement is not a [inaudible].
Legally they said he wouldn't
sign it and he signed it.
Why am I going to believe that he's not
going to use it after he said he's not
right. And then it gets even worse
because then it goes to federal court. Uh,
plaintiffs including a
former war correspondent, uh,
Chris Hedges used to work at
the New York Times and, uh,
Daniel Ellsberg who leaked
the Pentagon papers. Uh,
these are pretty credible people.
These aren't like quacks, you know, uh,
they filed a court case thinking,
uh,
with the intention of blocking this
because they said that MDA could basically
endanger their safety and the
safety of any journalist. You know,
if the government doesn't want
you talking about something,
let's just detain them without
a trial problem solved. Uh,
and the federal court judge
Catherine forest ruled it
unconstitutional. So again,
it should have stopped there.
But Obama's administration,
his lawyers are now appealing that, uh,
appealing that temporary injunction.
And so every single step of the way,
you're like, wait, if he doesn't want it,
why does it keep pushing for it?
You know,
so disturbing.
So it's just reeks of corruption and
it reeks of the worst intentions.
It reeks of looking at us like we're
sheep to be control of the intentions are
to crush dissent to cross.
There's the assumption that these
protests will continue to grow in,
in relevance and in size, and there's
the assumption that the economy,
if there's not some kind of
economic collapse, who knows?
It could just be years of slow employment
and years of people being unsatisfied
and that's,
even if that's not a total calamity,
that's still a breeding ground for like
mass civil unrest and they've think if
we have this ability to imprison people
without a trial, just on our say,
so that's going to crush
dissent pretty fast.
The first thousand people will be arrested
and put in prison.
That's the end of it.
No more protesters because nobody else
is going to go out of their house. Well,
what's crazy though is that the people
who are arresting the people are on the
same side as those people.
They're just people that are working,
they're working folks,
the cops and the soldiers.
Those aren't the people
pulling the fuck strings.
The people that are going
to have to do the arresting,
whether it's military police
or whether it's regular police,
those are just fucking citizens with jobs.
They're not the power problem.
They're not the people
making the actual calls.
That's a small group of people that
we could easily overpower. Yeah.
Well that's why I was not,
I'm not calling for a revolution
when I have,
when I have trouble with the TSA.
Well now that I'm running for Congress,
like it's a little bit better because
if they, if they harass me too much,
they're actually interfering
with the democratic process.
Like they're making it so that I can so
that I can't catch my flight and can't
go to a fundraiser. I can't go to a media
interview. That's a big deal, you know.
Has anyone ever done that? No. It's been
pretty good. Uh, do you worry about that?
I don't worry about it.
I'm just, uh, what I,
what I worry about is what I
actually experienced every time,
which is I politely opt out of the
new screeners because those give off
radiation and they'd
been banned in Europe.
The European Union has banned this kind
of scanner cause they don't know the
long term health effects of
shooting radiation into your body.
A backscatter radiation. Uh, it,
it's a different form of radiation.
Then a chest x rays, I believe,
I'm not an expert on this,
but it's different because
it's doing a different thing.
It's taking a photo of basically the
outside of you instead of just blasting
right through your body to show your
bones on an x ray. So as a result,
it's a different kind of
radiation. And uh, so anyway,
these machines freak me out
to the point where I don't,
my testicles going through that, uh,
every single time I get on a flight.
So I politely opt out and there's
a sign right there that says,
if you'd like to opt out, let us know.
Uh, I opt out and then you're treated,
uh, in a way that's not very good.
They say, we have an opt out, sir.
Stand over there like you've
done something wrong, right?
It's not like, okay, cool.
Just give us a second. We'll get
to it. It's all about the attitude.
They said we have an opt out.
Stand over there.
And then travelers behind you see
that going on and they're like, shit,
I'm not going to opt out.
I'm just going to go through this thing.
And I'm gonna let my
kids go through it too.
I think that's what they're
trying to get. Yeah. No.
And then you get the invasive pat down
where you have to put your arms up by
your sides and you put your arms down
after a couple of minutes because you're
tired and you've just been on a long or
you're about to get on a long flight.
And uh, they say sir, hands back up,
put them back up and they guy sticks
his fingers down your belt and a ahead.
It was belt. Yes, he does. He do like
a scissors on the tip of your director.
He actually does touch the tip,
like you feel you feel pressure
against the tip of your penis.
Wow. And that's too much
for the government to be
doing. That's not their role.
You know,
uh,
like it's great that you're trying to
keep us safe and trying to keep airports
curity at a high level. That's not
your role. Nobody asks you to do that.
You shouldn't be doing that.
It's unconstitutional. And
so every time I'm like,
should I just go through the fucking
scanner and get it over with?
But every time I go, no, I have
to hold to this. Cause if you,
if you give them a pass on this, then at
what point do you just lose all of your,
uh, your compass there, you know?
Yeah,
I could see people like pilots and,
and people that didn't actually
have to go through it, right?
They have a different line.
And also if you pay
something like 100 bucks,
you can now get an expedited screening.
Got To do a background check beforehand.
I find that profoundly unconstitutional
to cause you're classing citizens,
what does this, the titanic, you know,
if you have extra disposable income,
we're not going to screen you as
closely as the masses. It's ridiculous.
I can't agree more.
I think it's so weird.
I was a in London the other day and
I was really tempted to do it because
there's two who's just,
there's a big ass line.
This dude just walked in with
that pre and snuck right through.
Didn't even have to take his shoes
off. It was like, but I'm just like,
what kind of access to they have when you,
what do they look for when you go in
and submit something like that and know
want to listen to your cell phone 24,
seven. Is that what you're agreeing to?
Just so you can, well then make
sure doing that just about, anyway,
that's not really happening.
So
Nsa thing,
uh,
there was a video about this and
the New York Times website recently,
it was an amazing video,
is like eight and a half minutes
long professionally produced, uh,
where they interviewed
the NSA whistleblower who
everybody's kind of heard
something about, but you don't
know his actual, you know,
what he's saying happened.
And this video lays it all out there.
It's amazing journalism.
Like,
I don't know why the New York Times
didn't put it on their homepage where it
belonged, but it still
got out there. You know,
it was on reddit and like all these
social media sites and they did a good job
of showing people that, uh,
I'll just boil it down. Um,
this NSA whistleblower,
his name is William Binney,
and he was at that agency for 32 years.
Uh,
and he was actually the technical
director there, so he was pretty high up.
He wasn't like just the analyst or
a janitor or something, you know,
he knew what was going on and he's about
as high up as you can get. And, uh,
so he says that after nine 11,
the NSA went from using their incredible
power to monitor stuff overseas,
which is their mandate
to do that, uh, you know,
tap into satellite phones and tap in
overseas internet traffic and all of that
stuff. They went from doing that
to turning this incredible, uh,
surveillance weapon
against our own people.
And it became a full blown effort to
record pretty much everything that we're
doing here in the u s uh,
and that includes, uh,
every citizen who has access to the
internet or a cell phone and the way they
get around this because it appears
to be blatantly unconstitutional.
The fourth amendment against
unreasonable searches and seizures. Um,
they have an interpretation from what the
whistleblower was saying in this video
or from the article.
They have an interpretation that we're
not actually violating your fourth
amendment rights because we're only taking
this information in and storing it in
our databases. We're not actually,
there's nobody with, you know,
a pair of headphones and a computer
screen in front of them who's watching you
type every email and actually
looking through all of your stuff.
We're just saving this. But the
problem with that is it's saved, uh,
and it's tied to your name
and all they have to do.
It's not a big logical leap to think,
uh,
if you're running for Congress and
you might be running on a platform,
you want to doubt, you want to defund some
of these programs, they go, let's look.
Let's look into this guy.
You know,
they type in your name and they
suddenly see all of your emails,
all of your phone calls,
all of your associations,
because that's part of what it does.
It does threading and shows your
community who you talk to online, uh,
who you call on your cell
phone. Supposedly that's what
this thing is capable of.
Uh, so it shows them all this
information and they can cherry pick.
Maybe they go through an email from
three years ago where jokingly I said,
you know, with a friend, uh, you know,
yeah dude, fuck the u s you know,
and they just quote that I think should
this guy be running for Congress,
you know,
and like bring bogus charges against you.
There's so many ways they can screw you
over when they have access to all of
your information. And so people
out there go, they're not gonna,
they're not watching me.
And that's true.
Nobody with a pair of headphones is
listening to your every word on the cell
phone. That's not how
this is working. Instead,
it's being archived and giving them
tremendous access to screw you over should
you become a problem to them. I think
again, that's the power of the government.
Shouldn't have,
I couldn't agree more. It's a, and the
government shouldn't want it right now.
I think the real issue is that we've
developed an US versus them divide between
the government of the people. And he
shouldn't be that at all. You know,
it shouldn't be them defending
their power position. It should be.
They are us and we,
they are representatives are us and
they're looking out for us legitimately
right. And clearly that's been
corrupted and that's not good for them.
It's not good for the people
that are perpetrating.
This is not good for you either, man.
You, you might be profiting off of it,
but it's horrible for your life.
That's the only,
that's the only ray of uh,
really the only ray of light here is that
this program is so vast and Orwellian
to be honest, if what this
whistleblower says, it's true,
it's so vast that it's also our
calving information on senators and
representatives and FBI agents,
people at the very top of government.
And those people don't really want
that, you know, they don't want, uh,
for some agency that's
basically unaccountable to
be able to screw them over at
any point in the future.
So I think that's kind of the thing there
that might save us in the end is that
some powerful people in DC might say,
wait a second, this is totally ridiculous.
Well,
I know we said that at the end of this
technology connection that we have,
it's gonna, it's gonna rush upon
us so quickly that you're not,
you're not even gonna know what hit you.
And then at a certain point in time,
there will be no more privacy.
It will won't exist.
That would be, that would be
something that you can get used to.
If it was two ways. Yes, I no longer have
any privacy. This is the 21st century.
The government knows and I'm walking
around on the sidewalk and I better not be
committing a crime against anybody else.
Uh,
but in exchange I want to
see where our money's going.
I want to see why we need
to still be in Afghanistan.
I want to see why you're
funding a multibillion dollar
storage facility in Utah,
uh, which the NSA is going to
be using to store all this data.
Like I want to see the numbers.
So then what's going on right now?
Absolutely happening right
now. It's not a plan. No.
If you can you actually bring up
the New York Times video. Sure. Uh,
can you bring it up Brian?
And so we
can see it on the scale. I'll try. It's
called, uh, it's called the program. Um,
so you're freaking me out by the way.
Thanks. This is like the, the first,
I was hoping,
I was hoping this would a be a good
opportunity to talk about this stuff.
What's it called? Yeah, say it
again. What's it called again?
The article is called like the program.
Just search for the program.
William Binney New York Times.
You just,
you've described it better than any I've
heard anybody describe it in the most
honest and ominous way.
Right. Well, like that,
that's the thing about this is it's not,
it's not that right now, by the way,
the NSA supposedly employees,
uh,
they employ more people then
the CIA and the FBI combined.
So when people say they don't have the
capacity to spy on you, actually they do.
They have the funding and they
have the employees to do it and no,
like they really aren't
listening in on your every word,
like a Jason Bourne movie, what
they're doing. There's the video
and this is in Bluff Dale, Utah.
For folks that are looking at home,
we're just looking at some
frozen landscape and it
says following nine 11 the
national security agency,
Mccann,
a top secret surveillance program to
spine US citizens without warrants,
Codenames,
stellar wind or the program to insiders.
The full scope of the surveillance.
This has not been made public.
It is raining Severen Maryland.
There's a man who's doing heroin
now. He needs glasses, king,
different codes and uh,
and data systems.
And he's an NSA whistleblower
doing data beneath those lips.
The Soviet Union,
he worked at the NSA for 32 years.
He is regarded as one of
the best mathematicians and
code breakers in the NSA's
history.
Yep.
They're nine 11 they took one of the
programs I would have done or the backend
part of it and started to use it to
spy on everybody in this country.
So and that that was a program
they created called stellar wind.
That was the separate and compartmented
from the regular activity that was
ongoing because it was
doing domestic spying.
All the equipment was coming out.
I knew something was happening,
but then when my,
the contractors I had hired came and told
me what without what they were doing,
it was clear where all the hardware was
going and what they were using it to do.
It was simply a different input.
Instead of being foreign,
it was domestic employees.
Somebody told me to pick him, listen
to what we're saying by my having us,
even if it's turned off. Yes, here's
the, here's the real grand design.
Every domain,
think of a domain as an activity,
a specific type of activity,
phone call or banking is another domain.
So if you think of graphing
each domain and then each graph,
then turning it in.
The third dimension.
The trick now is to map through all
the domains and that third dimension,
pulling together all the attributes that
any individual has in every so that now
I can pull your entire life together
from all those domains and map it out and
show your entire life over time.
Jesus Christ, this is crazy. Should
we address this whole thing? Oh,
let's watch a little bit more,
more frozen landscape.
The NSA is currently building the
country's biggest data storage facility in
bluffed.
Dalian.
Tom,
yeah.
You got to watch the next two minutes
cause he talks about when the FBI raided
him.
So
Betty calculates the facility as a
capacity to store 100 years worth of the
world's electronic communication.
I don't understand why not. What should
I do? Because what you're saying,
if it was possible,
it would be revolutionary and people
would have invested interest in preventing
that from happening. I'm
too old. I'm too old.
Whoa.
I'm too old.
That's a scary thing to say.
I'm not sure how many of you got a
chance to hear Keith Alexander yesterday,
the head of the NSA.
I talk about the NSA's activities bill,
how do you reconcile,
is there some way to reconcile general
Alexander statement to that the NSA is
and keeping track of every American with
the existence of a facility like the
one in Utah,
NSA charter and it was illegitimate.
My one was to do foreign intelligence
and I was with that all the way and I did
the best I could in their job.
Unfortunately they took those programs
as I build and turned them on you.
I'm sorry for that.
I didn't intend that,
but they did that to what
you're describing really
is a hard to reconcile with
the laws as the laws are
generally understood by the
lawyers who work with them.
Most people are familiar with the
Webster's definition of intercept.
You said 18 has a different
definition and that's uh,
an intercept doesn't take place until
it's actually listened to it until
somebody puts on,
on some earphones or actually
read some text on a screen.
So you can pull in all the
communications you want.
The acquisition isn't a search in the
querying later on is a search and they can
then keep it in their database and
target after the fact by going back and
conducting data mining searches
afterwards. In other words,
to get the information that they couldn't
target from the outset and there is
another real problem.
Unfortunately the software
will want to take some data.
It will build profiles on
everybody in that data.
Okay. Jesus Christ,
you're like olive garden.
The purposes to be able to monitor
how they're going to know about me.
Yeah. Sorry to bring the vibe down by
recommending this video. By the way,
this has been haunting my
dreams like this is real. Yeah,
but do you think most p look have to
worry about this? Like carrying that?
They do this about you hold on,
hold on,
turn style you the outline at the life
of everybody in the community and if you
carry it over time from 2001 up,
you have that 10 years worth of their
life that you could lay out in a timeline.
Then involves anybody in the country,
even senators and House of
Representatives. All of them.
The dangers here are that we fall into
something like a totalitarian state like
East Germany in July,
2007 the FBI raided the homes of many
and two other NSA whistleblowers. Well,
they came in guns drawn, you know, in my
house. They didn't do that to the others,
but they did to me, I guess. I Dunno.
They thought I was probably the most
dangerous at all. So I don't know.
I didn't know what was in their minds.
Okay. So, but they did that and,
and they came in and pointed the gun at
me when I was getting out of the shower
at the time. So they pointed a gun right
in my old head, you know what I'm saying?
Hey, so Jesus Christ, I wasn't too upset.
I just said, uh, yeah, I suppose I
can get it. I could get dressed here,
tried to, they weren't intimidating me
anyway. So Tommy, something that will,
a intimidating, implicate somebody in
a crime. That's what they asked me.
So I told them what the crime was that
I knew about and that was that, uh,
George Bush and Dick Cheney tenant.
And Aiden conspired to
subvert the constitution and
constitutional process and
any number of laws.
And here's how they did it.
And I explained stellar wind on my back
porch to all the FBI agents who weren't
cleared.
So he had a problem.
I created a problem for them because
they had a bunch of people now who aren't
cleared for a very highly classified
only because it was domestic spying.
By the way. What's the reason? It
was highly classified. You know,
they wanted to highly classify the
extreme impeachable crimes, right?
They were committed.
Top Justice Department
officials threatened to
resign in 2004 because stellar
wind violated the law. They're legal
objections to the program or not.
We should take turns. Democracy
need to say, do you read,
do we want our government to have
this data or not? And if, if so,
if we want them to have it,
then what kind of controls and they have
to be a little bit when we're invisible,
it can't all be done in secret.
It can't have secret interpretations of
laws and run them at secret and not tell
anybody or can't make up kill list.
And not telling anybody what the criteria
is for being in the kill is. Okay.
It's raining again.
That's a very, very disturbing. That just
really fucked my head sideways. Well,
when I saw that my initial reaction was
why isn't this on the homepage at the
New York Times? Like they're
putting their name behind this.
This is real journalism. It just
came out like last week. Uh,
this should be everywhere. That's,
that's the problem I have, by the way,
with some of the mainstream media,
you know,
people have tweeted this video
out to everybody, you know,
it's gotten out in the media and for
some reason like, oh, this isn't news,
we're just going to run with
Kim Kardashian was stumbling
out of some nightclub.
And by the way, they might be
spying on every single person,
but it's not important. Holy Shit. Uh,
so, well this is not, they might be, it's,
it seems like they are the only, the only
credibility issue is it comes down to,
do you believe William Binney and the
other whistle blower, Thomas Drake. If,
if this guy's full of Shit, then the
whole story is called an the question,
but the problem is he
was a very high ranking.
He was there for 32 years and they don't
want psychos work at the NSA like they
do some pretty serious psychological
background stuff.
From what I understand.
The other thing on top of that
is this guy was a respected,
brilliant mathematician. He's
like a John Nash, you know,
this isn't some like dumb dude had
got caught up and some paranoia.
It's more like, although I guess
John Nash did exactly do that,
but the point is he's a very smart
guy who is working at a high level and
despite how intelligent he is,
he realized, wait a second,
this is just profoundly wrong
and it's not our mandate.
It's not what we should be doing.
And I'd love the fact that he explained
it all to the cops as they arrested him.
That's the other thing.
The FBI agents are already pretty high
up in terms of clearance level and the
fact that that blew their
minds and they're like, wait,
what is this stellar wind program?
That's scary stuff is scary stuff.
And the, the, the beautiful thing
is when he does explain them,
I mean if you listen to that guy talk,
when he did explain it to them,
I'm sure it made a lot of them questioned
why they were arresting him. Right.
And question whether or not he was in
fact a patriot and not a bad guy. Right.
Like what we're buying. That's
a red flag word. Why is it,
why is this old man in the
shower a threat to our security?
Yeah, it sounds ridiculous. I mean
cause he's a super mathematician.
What is he a fucking Batman
comic book character.
He's gonna fucking develops a mathematical
formula to overthrow the world by
hacking into your email account.
Come on. Yeah, that video. The video
has been haunting my dreams though.
That's the sand. It's been like, it's kind
of a, it tells you about your friends.
Like I've been emailing it to people
and when I get an email back saying,
holy shit, that's terrifying. Like good
thing you're running for Congress. Ha Ha.
And I'm like, I'm like, you're screwed.
There are real stakes involved.
Like,
people don't get it.
Like if you want to keep the same
representatives you have now who were
supportive of this stuff,
good luck. Well the but uh,
sorry to cut you off. Please
do. Uh, sometimes, uh,
you get an email back or somebody
who's like, whatever dude.
Like they just don't care.
And I'm like,
how far gone or you that you don't care
about this. Yeah. Those people are silly.
I care about it,
but I don't think I've,
I do anything really insanely wrong
where I'm fearing it. Know what I mean?
Like I've, I mean, I don't think it's that
big of a deal. It sucks. If it's true,
I wish I would say no, don't do it.
Right. But let me paint a scenario. Cared.
Let me paint a scenario for you.
Okay.
Since you always date all
these lovely ladies. All right.
What if a one of your lovely ladies
would come like you gotta to take a leak?
Yeah.
What if one of you lovely ladies had
come in contact with a certain politician
now at a very high ranking position and
this guy just decided that he wanted a
bang your wife,
so he gets you locked up and put
in jail and you have no recourse.
And he pulls up some email where you
said, you know, something crazy, you know,
10 years ago,
joking and completely trolling it.
But because of the fact that he asked me,
what has this written down into your name,
that's it going to arrest you. I know.
That's insane. It is. But it's something
that they'd be able to do. Yeah,
but that's the phrase, you know, I
was watching CNN the other night,
it's not that crazy.
And this is why I was watching the CNN
the other night and they had a guy who,
um,
is a cop who is a under questioning for
two people's deaths and they think he
might've been, uh, like a, a some time
serial killer. And that this cop, uh,
he, uh, there's two people disappeared.
Any of the same story for both of them,
that he dropped him off at the
circle k and a, one of them was a,
a Mexican guy who couldn't speak
English and the other one was this, uh,
this black guy and they think that, uh,
this cop might've killed these people.
And why did he do it?
Because he could because he could because
he had the power is in that position.
He had a gun pulled over the lights go on,
he calls into thing,
calls in the car and said that, uh, he,
he had two totally different stories and
one story he found the car abandoned.
And in the other story he actually
did a background check on the guy.
So he actually called in a
background check that like the,
the whole thing is the guy turns out
missing and he has like this cockamamie
story about taking the guide to the
circleK and calling the circle k and that,
that record's not on his phone,
you know, is an official phone.
What I'm saying is that this
guy was a cop. They just
decided to kill people. Why?
Because he had the power of you get
some guys some high position of power,
one of those little sweet pieces
of ass that you carry around. Dude,
you never know. You never
know. Motherfucker might
just turn on your boxes.
You can't let someone, you cannot let
someone have that kind of power. They,
that there's no reason for it.
There's plenty of recourse right now.
Someone does something wrong.
We don't need to like up the amount of
power that the government has over it.
I guess I have way too big of a,
I had a positive,
not negative skew being delusional.
I like being delusional with this shit
like it. But you know what? I was in Ohio,
which,
uh,
I forgot how bad the police state
and Ohio was like everywhere you go,
you saw cops on the,
on an hour drive from Columbus to date.
And I had seven p like cop car pulled
on the side of the road with the guns
pointing at your cars, you know, that
still trappings seven. And then, uh,
one night I was hanging out with Bert
Kreischer, his shows. I did a spot and uh,
uh, I had a couple of drinks, you know,
at the show there's going to go
to Mcdonald's and go to my hotel.
So I go to Mcdonald's, go through the
drive through, I'm going to park my car,
you know, to eat it. And that parking
lot was too crowded for Mcdonald's,
so there was like another
parking lot attached to it.
It was like a big boy that was a, it
was close. So I just pull right through,
you know, right out of there, the
drive through right into it, you know,
with my lights on, eating my mic
riddle and suddenly two cop cars,
both sides lights on like,
and they're like off a third,
what are you doing in your car?
And I'm like,
they're like shining lights on my face.
And I'm like, ah, I'm eating a McGriddle,
you know, like show it to
'em out the window. And uh,
they came up to my car and there
goes, uh, let me see your license.
I showed him my license and it, and it was
just like, holy shit man. Like now what?
They're going to make me do like a drunk
test and because I had three beers in
the last two hours,
like now I'm going to get a Dui because
I'm sitting here eating and Mick griddle.
And then he's asking me all
these questions like, what
are you doing? I'm like,
I did a comedy to it and I, uh, you know,
the funny bone. And he goes, uh, uh,
he's like, oh, how was it? And
I'm like, it was fine. He goes,
you've been drinking tonight.
And I go, no, that was the
first time I ever said no.
Like I had three drinks, but I'm like,
I'm just going to say no this time.
Cause I had a griddle all over my face
and I was still eating when he's actually
asking me these,
I played it off
like, what the fuck are you doing
dude? Like I always like, you know,
and so I'm rubbing Madrid all
over my face and uh, uh, he goes,
okay, you're free to go. And I'm
like, free to go for doing what?
I'm parking my car,
eating a McGriddle came up.
They always make you feel
like you're in the wrong,
but they let you get get away this
time. You know, Ross, they're us.
They're not the Illuminati.
That's what's the most fucked up thing
about you give people arbitrary power
over other people. Exactly. That's why
he can't have laws like that folks,
state and police have the, we give
you a nice things and you break them.
You can't have that and it's
not good for them either.
It's not good for you to be
in a position like that over.
It's not good for your Karma.
At the end of the day,
you're unhappy because I've
found this like if you're,
if you treat other people in a shitty way,
and maybe for a short amount of time,
you get that little ego high,
but over time it's like you to
pay for it comes back. Exactly.
Waterfall of suck and it crushes you
with the rebound and always does.
It just is no way to live these people.
And by the way,
that's not the only way to get
rich to look at Ted Turner.
I bet that guy's got plenty of money.
Right? They actually on CNN. Yeah.
But he's like, no, no, no.
He's out. I think he's out.
I think he's disgusted with maybe that's
why it's so fucked up. Yeah. Like he,
he sold it to,
I guess like a w like AOL Time Warner
became this big thing. But anyway,
I shouldn't use him as an example
anyway because quite honestly,
I don't really know that much
about his past. He always,
but he always seemed like it wasn't a
bad guy, just like a smart businessman.
It didn't seem like a Richard Branson.
He seems like an awesome guy.
That's much better example. Thank
you. Richard Branson seems like, like,
like some kind of crazy
billionaire and a movie. Like,
I'm going to get an a
balloon and travel the globe.
I'm going to get a space
ship going to Mars. I mean,
he really does seem like that guy.
So fucking super, super, super.
Read his article about,
uh, drug policy. No,
I did incredible on the Virgin did if
we're on the virgin corporate websites,
so he puts his corporate name
behind it, virgin.com. He, uh,
put this letter saying,
you know,
we should all look at the
Portugal decriminalization
project the past 10 years.
They're doing decriminalization. It works.
Is this, about a year ago he did this,
uh, maybe a little less than that
around then. Uh, when he did that,
people were like,
okay,
we have to actually look at this
study because he's a serious guy.
A lot of people don't realize that
Portugal decriminalized all drugs. Uh,
it was it a decade ago,
a decade ago,
essentially made it so that
everything is legal. And what,
what's crazy is that they're violent.
Crime has dropped,
their rates of addiction have dropped.
Um,
clinics have less people in them that
needed help, that are, that are addicted.
So it's kind of amazing. It's
when you let people, you know,
you don't try to nanny
state the fucking world.
People have this weird thing where if
you tell them they can't do something,
they want to do it. They, it's
weird. When something's illegal,
it makes it an intoxicating and makes
it exciting for people. You know,
it's whereas as well,
and there were also some things that are
so good that even if they're illegal,
you're going to try it anyway. Sure.
You know, booze, they, they tried that.
They tried, uh, you know, that was,
that's another example of legislation
where you have good intentions but nobody
did the math on it. Yeah. And,
and really not even good
intentions because you can't
tell people what to ingest
and the privacy of their own home.
I understand their point.
I understand the point of the, the
really clean, straight edge people.
I have friends that are straight edge.
Totally fine.
I shouldn't have to impose it on the
whole country. You're right, you're right.
But what they think is that it worked
for them and there's no way it could, uh,
it could be different for you. You,
in your case, if you're drinking,
if you like to go out and do shots
and hang out with Bert Kreischer,
you are having a problem, you've
got a problem. And you know,
obviously I don't agree with that,
but I see where their
intention is coming from.
I see why they wanted to try
to do it in the first place.
They wanted to try to clean up America,
America,
even back then in the
1920s it's filled with sin.
It was the roaring twenties
everybody was fucking nuts.
They were having these speakeasies they
get together and bang. It was craziness.
There were animals. It's pretty awesome
actually. Fucking fantastic. No texting,
you know. All you can have to say is,
I don't know what she's talking about.
And you were done. You were out of
it. There was no good age though.
Were they my kid? You agreed to
meet somebody and you just met them.
There is no like last minute changes
and like, and how'd you meet him again?
You have to find where they live and
that's why cities are so beneficial.
There was no communication.
There's no phones.
We had to find where they live or how
do people get around before the maps on
phones? Well, I remember
living in Boston and you know,
meeting people and walking everywhere.
I mean I remember when I was a kid from
high school on like we fucking walked
everywhere.
We would walk like miles to the t to the,
to the train to get into Boston.
We just walk miles.
Kids today don't do that kind of shit.
There's no kids walking my,
they're texting each other. They don't
have to go and meet each other in person.
They don't have to go and
hope they run into each other.
We didn't even have answering machines.
You call people if they weren't home.
Tough Shit.
It's been a weird thing for me as a human
being to have come of age should be a
teenager and with the,
with the invention of the answering
machine and seeing that and going, wow,
you mean so we can fucking leave a
message and you're not even here.
Like what a mind blower that was
for me to sing this video. Yeah.
Of what kind of information is being
and how much they can know about every
credit card transaction. I
think that's the, the other, uh,
the other thing about, you're
saying earlier about like
where things really, uh,
maybe things were just as bad back then,
but we didn't know about it because
we didn't have the Internet.
I think part of it is they would have,
maybe they wanted this kind of thing,
but they just didn't have the
technology to do it to pull it off.
It would just be it be possible to do
this thing would require like hiring
millions of operators and you just,
you can't do that.
But it's an example of the
ethic that's always been there.
It's the US versus them mentality that
is accelerating because of the fact
there's so much civil
uprising around the world.
I mean we really are getting to this
really ridiculous point where, you know,
the Mayan apocalypse date
of 2012 December 21st date,
it's completely ridiculous that these
guys had figured out when the world was
going to fall apart. Yet. How weird is it
that the world is fucking falling apart?
It's closing in on that day. How
many earthquakes? We had a yesterday,
it's hundreds of earthquakes.
There was one area that at hundreds of
earthquakes I think we actually have,
like, I think the US has a really
bright future, but I think, uh,
it's kind of all a house of cards.
Like you have to be very careful.
You start pulling out certain cards and
undermining faith in certain things and
before you know it, you don't have a
society anymore. You have, you know,
with the Mayans experienced to their
society vantage or broke down or whatever
the hell happened to them.
Yeah.
It's not just that these
people shouldn't be corrupt.
It's that when you are corrupt and when
you are in a position where you are not
looking out for the
greater good of mankind,
you're ruining the entire
process of acceleration.
You're ruining it and subverting it and
making it a selfish thing and making all
the, all the things that don't
get corrected as we move forward.
It's like say if you were a little kid
and you just decided you were going to
shit in the middle of your bedroom
because you didn't feel like going to the
bathroom, you have your own choice.
Nobody can tell you what to do.
So you just say you're five, you're
like, I'm just going to shit right here.
You pull your pants down and shit and
then you make a little pile and your
bathroom and then you always
think you're going to clean up,
but you never get around to it.
I mean,
that's essentially what the
human races to the world,
which is leaving shit places and just
assuming we're eventually gonna get to
some point,
we're going to clean it up instead of
dealing with it first and foremost,
before we start fucking around with the
governments and other parts of the world,
and before we start fucking around
with tap at People's phones,
let's figure out a way how to get oil
out of the fucking ocean without killing
everything.
Let's figure out a way to let the dolphins
live and not have shrimp be fucking
poison.
Let's figure out a way to not putting
a tire economy out of work because you
fucking assholes wanting to finish your
drill early so you've used cheaper parts
are less stringent. Set up. Amen.
Get on that first and
then let's fade Iran.
That's the other thing
that outrages me so much.
You see a video like that and
he's, and it's not only like, okay,
they're violating our rights.
And there are creepy implications for
how this can be used at some point,
but it's,
this is a colossal waste of money.
This is billions and billions of dollars
and this is only one program that we
know about it. We don't know what other
creepy programs are out there right now.
And uh,
how that same amount of money could
be used on things where you see a real
tangible impact on people's communities.
Like teachers don't get paid. Well,
cops don't get paid well. No. Uh,
and maybe if we paid people
better and have better incentives,
we would get better people.
That's how it is in every other industry
and it should be an honorable position.
I've always said that being a teacher
should be a position of respect and
honoring this country.
And it should be something
that's very difficult to achieve.
We should know that you are of of great
character, that you're a good person,
that you're looking at life in the right
direction, you know, a creepy pervert.
We should know all these things about
you and when we should respect the fact
that you're going to be
spending time with our kids.
And some of that spending time with
your kids has profound influence.
They're teaching them things.
Yeah, it's really dangerous.
You can't even put a money. Uh,
you can't even put a price on the impact.
You can have either good or bad.
I had a civics teacher in seventh grade.
He's part of the reason why I'm
interested in politics today because, uh,
he did this crazy experiment that I
feel like every teacher should do.
We were in a private school at the time,
so you're allowed to get
away with more stuff.
And a public school prior would
have been sued. Uh, but what he did,
we walked into class one
day. It just seemed like a
normal class, right? And, uh,
we walk into class and he says,
okay, uh, if you have brown eyes,
you have brown eyes sit in the front two
rows. If you have a, you have blue eyes,
I want you in the back of the room. And
he just segregated us by Eichler. And, uh,
at first people were like, okay,
this is some kind of joke, you know,
he's just messing around and you'd say
you and call on someone with Brown eyes
and give them preferential
treatment over the blue eyes.
I think I'm actually messing this up.
I think it was the other way around.
Like it people who have blue
eyes doses. Yeah, exactly.
If you looked area and uh,
you were in the,
you are in the front and if you
didn't you were in the back. And uh,
so he starts asking questions and
whenever somebody in the back was asked a
question answered, he
said, no, that's wrong.
You obviously didn't do the homework
last night. You have to read up. This is,
even if it was a great answer and it was
starting to fuck with people mentally
where these people were getting better
treatment and the people in the back
based entirely on Eichler. By the end of
that class there were girls crying and,
and guys too, like people were crying
and like, what's up? And they were like,
is this real? Like what's wrong
with this guy? Why is it doing this?
It's my answer was good and then at the
end then at the end he told us he was
just running an exercise to show us what
it's like when you have inequality and
for somebody using a suburban white
kid, you're like, that must suck.
To feel that all the time. You
know, it's a deep experiment.
I think every teacher should do that,
and that wasn't the only thing he did,
but the point is he had a profound
impact and he probably made a very small
amount of money for doing it.
That's a beautiful idea, man.
That's a beautiful way of pointing it out.
Show it,
show it to people and let them know
that it was just an act, but show,
show them what is possible.
You know, there's, look,
there's a lot of racism in this country
that's undeniable and it's one of the
grossest things about human beings, but
classism, all that shit is just as bad.
Any,
any,
any distinction where you automatically
put someone in a desert where you'll put
your prejudging marginalized.
I've met some rich people who suck and
I met some really rich people who are
just amazing. Absolutely you don't. You
don't judge somebody by their income.
I've always been offended that people
think you're an idiot because you exercise
and perhaps someone who fucking stupid
conversations with people that are like,
Oh, good work in your
body. Meet Hood. I'm like,
go stay in shape and why is that
marginalize me because I'm in shape half
everybody that lifts weights has to be
a more on really is that convenient for
you? You don't have to compete.
Certainly not good for evolution.
It's so ridiculous.
People are just slowly trying
to stop what is inevitable.
They're clawing at what is
inevitable and what's inevitable.
It's ultimate accountability for
everything, all of your actions,
and then it's eventually going to
move from that to being your very
thoughts.
There's going to be the next phase of
technology unquestionably is going to be
some sort of fucking interface where
people are going to be able to read each
other's minds or communicate without any
sort of noise coming out of your mouth.
I think that is 100% common.
I think we're going to be able to
communicate things in visual form as well.
I think you're gonna be able to
communicate memories eventually.
You're going to be able to lock heads
with someone and show them your day and I
don't think that's out.
And I think your memory is going to be
more phenomenal than the current fucking
weird slide show that you have now. Blurry
images that you barely can remember.
It just what I did today.
If you asked me how I what?
What exactly happened from the moment
you woke up? Can you remember every no,
no I don't. I remember playing with
my kids. I remember getting in my car,
this is blocks, little little
flashes, a little slideshow.
You'll be able to pull all of that shit.
You'll be able to pull every second
software. It's going to make it
probably Google goggles, bitch. No, no,
that software. We just watched
that video on the New York Times.
It's probably going to be like,
you want to see my day?
Here's an exact DVR of my day, but I
edited out like two hours of poop of me.
Boop beating off on the
toilet with two Q tips.
That's the ultimate sin beating off on
the toilet while you're have a qtip in
your air and shit. So bad for you man.
Taking a shit rubbish. Q-Tips. Yeah,
they're terrible for you man. You need
to just get it done. Once I had loved my,
no, no, no, I do. I just, I
need to wait. Qtip it's bad.
Some times you shouldn't
be digging in your ears.
What are you supposed to do that
and cause your wax builds up.
He's supposed to get it cleaned,
cleaned out or they have like,
like ear juice that you can buy it.
It's like cvs,
he put it in there has like
this little plunger thing,
but you're the worst thing
you're not supposed to do.
That's where nowhere on the box for a
box of Q tips is it say put this shit in
your ear. Right? It's crazy.
So good though. It does.
Especially when you're taking a
shit and beating off. I told you,
I told you this Joe with my, I don't
know if I told her on podcasts of my,
this is my ex, she was cleaning
her ear out and then uh, she,
the phone rang so she picked it up and
she shoved the qtip inner ears start
gushing blood and pocket your drunk. Yeah.
You did talk about this on the podcast.
So watch this power, find ways
to die. The one where the uh,
she's getting a massage or no,
she's getting acupuncture and like rolls
off the bed and like one goes right
through her heart is how real.
I mean it has to be real.
It's a thousand ways to die.
What are they doing?
Shish Kebab needles on this bitch.
That doesn't even make sense.
How the fucking you get killed by
an acupuncturist scene of a pussy.
Are you that an acupuncture
needle is killing you?
Just went right through a heart.
I guess.
I almost think that shows
like creep show though.
Like I almost think that
it's like written. Um,
but I think, I think they
have to be factual Brazil
thing. It's based on I think.
I think it's supposed to
be here. I like, I like,
I almost think that's one of those shows
that they write stories like that. Yeah,
you could die.
Why wouldn't they have that as an option?
I mean they'd be crazy if the producers
didn't have that as an option. Yeah,
maybe you're right. Yeah. The act
of bumps or one doesn't make any
sense to me. That sounds crazy.
If it's on true TV, it has to be fake.
It's fucking completely ridiculous.
I don't think the acupuncture needles
could kill you like that cause it went
right through our heart so it
could have just, how's it going?
Right through your heart.
It's going to penetrate all that meat.
It's going to go through your bone.
What's it going to do is you got
to find the perfect, yeah. Really.
Maybe she had to bat Boone
hard. Maybe it's being, maybe.
Maybe if it fucking you landed on it
perfectly and it didn't bend maybe,
but really I wouldn't think that thing
would kill you. I wouldn't be too little.
Can I take an Alpha brand and
see if the next like ours.
I'm just curious like if I become really
smart all of a sudden go for dose. Well,
you're already super smart dude.
And you already saw articulate.
You're barely going to notice
here to smarter. Ready.
What this is for is mid level retards
like myself that can barely form sentences
without it. Oh actually
take, did you just chew it?
Oh, I was like, you're a fucking savage.
Imagine he just started snorting
it. Is this your Alpha brain? Yeah.
David Seaman running for Congress.
I caught starting drugs and the
Joe Rogan experience podcast.
They know it's a new tropic. It
doesn't count. Are you trying to,
is this a pee Dee for politics?
Should it be allowed next on Nightline?
Shit.
Nootropics be allowed.
Should we allow people to be smarter than
others when they could use it against
you? They'll have some like youtube video
of this 16 year old like artist took a
nootropic and like
I'm going to folks a butcher
then it was Salvia. They
totally villainize Salvia,
right? Cause they're like,
we found a couple of dudes on youtube,
millions of people have tried it
and it's legal in a lot of states.
We found some dudes on Youtube who acted
like assholes when after they took it.
Brian's one of them.
So clearly that's scientific.
Clearly based on what a couple
of people post on youtube,
we have to make this illegal and we
have to do a witch hunt against it.
It's fascinating that it was legal for
so long and such a potent psychedelic,
and it's, it's, I think it's very
indicative of the times we live in. It's,
people slowly figured that out
and started to sell it, you know,
because what you mean, that wasn't
around, what is it exactly? It's,
it's sage is what it is.
The word, the plants.
Sage is this sub Salvia divinorum target.
So it's just like, it's like I want
to target the plant form of it. Um,
well they also sell San Pedro cactuses.
You could buy those anywhere.
They're not illegal.
And that's the source of masculine.
That's the really the Carlos Castaneda
stuff. Well, Terrence, we can, uh,
famously, uh, on the big island of
Hawaii had a tropical rain forest garden.
He lived on, uh, the rain forest side
where it was beautiful up there. Man,
there's pictures of his
home was incredible.
He had this really cool pad he put up
there on the island and he had every
psychedelic plant known demand because
most of them grow breasts in these, uh,
these sort of a rain forest
environment. So breast, yes.
So you had it set up there. We had
Salvia, he had San Pedro cactus.
They're all legal. The, the, the, the
plant, what it, whatever it is, the uh,
Chicago Tree Veritas that they get
Iowasca from all these different plants.
He had them all growing.
They're all totally legal and beautiful
and fascinating to know that all of
these different plants,
I mean,
even if you just had them as
your little plant buddies,
you never even smoked him,
just kept them in your yard.
There's something kind of dope knowing
that you could literally change your
consciousness or some shit that's
growing next to your house,
knowing that has that kind of power.
Incredible power.
And Salvia is way more potent than
a lot of shit that is illegal. It's,
it's way more posed. Salvia is
really fucking strong. If you,
you get a real good dose of Salvia.
It is,
it removes you from Earth
for a short period of time.
It puts you in this really intense
hallucinogenic state. Can I,
can I admit that I've done Salvia?
I don't think that hurts me.
I don't think it hurts. Ya know, I did
an estate where it was legal and yeah,
so short acting,
it's like five minutes and I collapsed
and I felt I was actually a sheet of
paper, like a cosmic sheet of
paper. Yeah. It's weird stuff.
It's like a whippet of mushrooms.
It's like doing like a, it's so fast.
I couldn't find five minutes
later I was back to myself.
And it's not like you're stuck
there for hours, you know?
I only did it once and it didn't,
I don't think I did it right,
but I did it enough that it was really
creepy. Like on a podcast show. Yeah.
I don't think that's a good,
that's not something you would ever get
addicted to cause I was like, all right,
cool.
Did that,
like it took me over my own head and I
was looking down at myself and like these
pulsating waves,
uh,
to get like a new burst and new image
of me looking from like over here,
like up and to my right looking
down at me and I'm like, Ooh,
we like the Indian gods with all the
different hands. No, it was just me.
It was just me. I don't think
I had enough, like I said,
and it didn't last that long.
It was just a few minutes of an
out of body experience. But I was,
I remember thinking like,
how am I even seeing this perspective?
How am I seeing myself from here? Like
this is weird. How am I seeing it?
Or Am I getting a hallucination of the
idea that I'm saying? And he didn't know.
How crazy is it that you can just
walk into a store and buy it legally?
But my experience, I was still me. I
was still there. I didn't, you know,
I didn't leave the couch.
I've had people that have taken a lot
of it describe like really bizarre Ari
Shaffir talks about how he lived a whole
like several month period of his life
during a a 10 minute Salvia trip
while took it and then had all these
relationships and
friendships and had all this,
this whole different life like inception,
like the different layers where
the time gets messed up. Exactly.
And he said when he came back from
this 10 minute, you know, trip,
the Salvia trip, he had remembered
everything but it was just like,
he was just like coming out of a month
of a, you know, visiting your friends.
It's a month of like all of a sudden
you're here. How'd I get here?
That's so weird.
I really want to hear him talk that,
talk about that because that does
not sound like a Salvia trip at all.
I know it doesn't, but I don't
think they're all uniform.
I, I've heard so many,
like I said, mine was so simple. I didn't,
I definitely didn't have enough cause
it was just me. It was me above me.
It was weird images of me looking
down on me. It was nothing.
I didn't learn shit from it
other than like, this is weird,
but everybody that I know that's had
like big ones I've taken like big,
big experiences.
I know I didn't get a big enough hit,
but I could imagine if it could do that
with like the little baby hit that I had
where I wasn't even doing it.
Right.
Apparently you need like one of those
blow torch library collider. Yeah.
You need a blow torch lighter.
I had like a big,
and it just wasn't hot enough so it just
kind of tripped me out a little bit.
But apparently the blow torch light or
puts you into another fucking dimension.
Yeah,
it has to cook it to a certain temperature
in order to work stronger than weed.
That's way stronger than we can just
bond that you can just walk into a gift
shop and buy it. It's
so stupid. We need to,
and it's like that's actually
dangerous. Like, yeah.
And the sense that you could be an idiot
who walks in the gift shop buys or $15.
You pop it right there. You're,
you smoke it right there.
Although you can actually, I think
get it as a tea or something. You can,
I think so. Oh my God. Uh, so I,
I didn't do it as a tea though. I,
I smoked it,
but uh,
that the shit out of me is that the idea
that you can not like the idea that you
can get that legally and I
just walk out in the street,
you'll be just run over by a car.
Cars are going to be so out of it versus,
I mean, especially the t because who knows
how your body is going to process it.
What else was going to process it
differently because it's going through the
liver and the digestive system as
opposed to just going right into the
bloodstream with a smoke.
Now this isn't, yeah, this
isn't, if somebody sent, this
is a video of you doing it,
it's actually a campaign videos.
This is David Seaman Rolling.
Salvia
real conservative with his hippie
girlfriend. Well, I bet her feet steak.
Why do you want to guess?
I would not doubt
that
you ever see this tour? Yeah. Oh
yeah. I seen the shit. That's crazy.
When I broke the window,
it's crazy. It's almost no real
dude. He was almost like a Zombie,
like it's not real. I know. Almost like a
Zombie. It's fake. It's fake. That's fake.
Going to say that it's an
anti Salvia as it, yeah. Okay.
That seems a little over the top because
I remember the ones that people just
laughing and like screaming and stuff.
That's why I actually made a Salvia video.
Not because,
I mean I was like this is right
before everyone started doing it,
but like there was a few people doing
this cool before. It was cool now,
but there was few people that did salvia
videos and it was the funniest videos
to watch. Like I was
laughing, like I was addicted.
It was like dubstep from five years ago
and then I just wanted to try it and
then I wanted to make a
video of it because it was
fun watching yourself do it.
But now I feel like an asshole for doing
it because now every week kids doing it.
And why do you feel like
an asshole? Because I don't
think that should be legal.
Why not?
Because I think like like that,
that fun video that we just watched that
could happen or somebody could do it
while driving or or something like that.
I can't protect the
world from idiots Brian,
because then it keeps stuff
from you and I. Right.
But at least think it should have some
kind of 21 year old rating least or
something.
Some
maybe.
You know what I mean?
But I don't think it's rental
supervision after 18 years of age,
something like that. Yeah. To me
that just seems too dangerous.
Just because I,
I didn't,
I didn't know where I was for
seven minutes at the very least.
Like there should be an info packet
on the back. Like the same way as you,
you take a stupid drug for like allergies,
there's a packet.
It's like five pages long and telling you
all the possible reactions and what to
do. Right. Why don't to
have the same thing for that
and listen, this is nothing. It's not,
this is not like saying that it's a good
idea for everybody to do these things
because it's not,
I know a lot of people that can barely
handle regular reality and they should
not be fucking with Salvia or anything.
So to say that everything
should be illegal,
people should also have
people looking out for them.
People should also have people that they
can turn to to be educated on your own
choices. But I know people
that take mushrooms for a goof,
they just take it for fun. And guess
what? There's nothing wrong with that.
But I think we should have,
if we're going to,
if we're going to be an
honest society about,
about substances and
their effect on people,
we've gotta be honest about the positive
stuff too. You've got to be honest,
not just in people jumping out a window,
which is possible,
but you've got to also be honest about
people who go on mushroom chips and
become much better people.
Right?
And that's like a real
legitimate phenomenon that's
been documented in the John
Hopkins study that people have changed
their personality for the better because
at one intense mushroom trip that they
had where they experienced profound love
and connectivity and all
things that people like me
and my friends that have had
psychedelic experiences is all relayed.
Everybody realized the same thing.
It changes who you are,
changes the fundamental direction
in which your life is going.
And if we as a culture don't recognize it,
that is a potential
tool to help all of us,
including the people that are
in extreme positions of power.
They would have a better life if they
embrace this shit as well. And it's, it's,
well,
you can rule on,
on a deeper level if, yeah, if
you had an experience like that,
you can be more like a Marcus.
It really is like enlightened despot
instead of just the desperate, you know?
Absolutely.
Uh,
and really be looking out for the totally
looking after the interests of the
people. And there's reward in that. You
only need a certain amount of money.
You corrupt countries,
you don't get it.
You're caught up in a wave of addiction
and that addiction is to numbers because
after a certain while money doesn't
mean anything. You forget it.
It is nice to have a nice car.
It is really nice to live in a place where
you can come home and you have a nice
couch to sit in and a nice TV to watch
and a nice kitchen to cook your food and
a nice bed to sleep in. But after
that, everything else is horseshit.
Everything else you forget every be it's,
it's everything else is like,
what do you want a bigger watch.
One
look at more expensive. Should the
houses, the CEO of Goldman Sachs,
I wouldn't even want a house that
big people. It just seems creepy.
You need all that space to yourself.
They have these giant estates
that are 30,000 square feet.
I'd be, I'd be embarrassed.
I'd be embarrassed to bring
somebody back to that.
Yeah,
this is my house because they'd be like,
that's mentally ill. Like why do you need
this much space? You're like a hoarder,
but for houses,
30,000 square feet behind wanting to
how such a big house to represent you.
It's like Evander Holyfield when
he was the heavyweight champion,
built this enormous mansion in Atlanta
and he couldn't keep it up. He wound up,
I don't know if you want to be losing
it or what, but I remember he was,
he was in severe financial straits because
it was over $1 million a year just to
run this place just to run it.
$1 million a year.
Yes.
Keep your fucking lights on.
Did she?
The the the electricity
working and it's craziness.
People that are in that sort of a job,
if you're in the job of being like
Goldman Sachs sort of a guy and you have a
house like that,
it should be evidence of a sickness.
Someone should come along and go, wait,
why do you have Picasso's in your house?
Right? Why do you have on this shit?
What are you doing with all this shit?
You just, you're obsessed with
acquiring more and bigger shit.
You want a bigger private jet,
you want it.
And that would be fine if it wasn't for
you being in the position that you're in.
You being in a position where you get
to manipulate the fuck and market and
literally changed the economy with your
corruption and then get rewarded with a
taxpayer bailout.
Like we've never lived in
more transparent times of,
of the people at the top
of the heap being sick.
The people at the top of the heap all
need to get into a fucking sweat lodge
with some native Indians high. Yeah.
And they pass around the Mescalin.
Well, it's also like, uh,
the role of that person has changed now
he's isolated in his huge 30,000 square
foot mansion. I'm away from normal people.
I think just the generation ago. I mean,
I'm only basing this on some
stuff I've read and mad men,
which is not accurate at all. But I mean,
just basing it on what I've heard from
my parents and what I've read about.
If you're the CEO of a company,
uh,
you also felt like you had some
kind of role within the community.
You didn't want to be known
as a scumbag or like, Hey, uh,
whoever the Enron guy was,
that wasn't the end goal was
to con thousands of people
out of their retirements.
You're supposed to be this kind of
innovator that people respected and yeah,
you made more money,
Iacocca sorta exactly like you were
making more money then because you're
actually doing more and making it happen.
But at the end of the day,
you didn't want to just conned everybody
then live hundreds of miles away from
them. You know, you wanted to be a part
of the society. Cons. Yeah. Yeah. There's,
there's no reason for them to be making
that kind of money doing what they're
doing anyway. It doesn't make any sense.
You're not providing anything real.
You're moving numbers around
you crazy assholes. Why?
Why are so many of them going to you?
Can I play devil's
advocate on that one too?
Cause I have some friends who work in
finance. And although I agree with you,
that's, it seems like it's not
the best use of our resources,
especially when you have the absolute
smartest people out of college getting
recruited these firms instead of going
to NASA or going into medicine or any of
these other fields. Money. Yeah. Yeah.
But to play devil's advocate
a few hundred years ago, uh,
we explored the whole
world and did a lot of,
a lot of crazy stuff over spices and
spices to take it for granted. You know,
you walk over to target
and buy some spices,
but back then they would conquer people.
They would build ships,
they would chart out the whole globe
with these sophisticated maps stuff that
had never been done before.
All about bringing spices
back. And maybe today like,
yeah,
it's bullshit that these guys on computers
are fighting each other for imaginary
money.
But maybe at the end of the day,
it's also improving our technology in
ways that we haven't anticipated. Uh,
like I read an article about that, that,
uh, trading now is so, so high frequency.
If they have companies that build private
radio networks just to get the trade
out there like a 10th of a second faster.
Wow. The whole companies, like there's a,
there's a stock exchange in Chicago,
the Mercantile Exchange and it has to
communicate with the New York Stock
Exchange and a,
there are private companies that will
feed that data back and forth over a
private microwave network.
It's a series of relays,
the direct line of microwave or whatever.
And the benefit it provides them as
literally it's in the milliseconds.
But that difference when
you're dealing with, you know,
thousands of trades and
billions of dollars,
it ends up being profitable to
do that stuff. That's amazing.
Yeah. And I, I definitely
could see that point,
but my point is that we should never
have a society that's based on the
confidence in different options
and stocks and companies.
It's based on confidence and it flows
and wait, all that shit is scary.
All the derivatives fine,
all that shit is terrifying.
I W I read a Matt Taibbi article on the,
the uh,
the actual derivative economy being
something like 10 times larger than the,
the, you know, the speculative economy is
10 times larger than the actual account.
When we get enough bad bets,
everything goes down.
It's nuts.
It's crazy and it's not necessary.
It is a symptom of a corrupt time and
we need to abandon it. It's nonsense.
This whole Federal Reserve thing is nuts.
All that shit is nuts.
We need to figure out some in some way
where we can trade resources in a fair
way.
We need to figure that out and we're
not going to figure that out while these
monsters have a death grip on the economy
because that's what we're running into.
These big banks are a hundred times
more oppressive than the big government.
And then we see what the big governments
doing. Well, the big banks, they just,
it just clawing and suck
in and biting your neck.
They just trying to suck all the
blood out of you. They can, you know,
and they're terrified if
any sort of rebellion.
That's why Bank of America
retracted their $5 ATM fee.
Oh,
that was,
I wrote some articles about that stuff
and that was interesting because that got
people mobilize pissed and then it's like,
what about the,
you know,
$700 if you're working couple,
it's something like $700 a month of the
money you pay in taxes is going to like
war effort and all that stuff.
It's like,
why aren't you protesting
about these things? Is it,
is it something where like if it doesn't
immediately affect your purchase at
Starbucks,
you're not willing to talk about it.
But like if you can see it so
tangibly that you're like, fuck,
there's $5 less than my account,
then you go out and you're like, no,
we're switching to a credit union.
But the other stuff doesn't you,
you know it's pretty Primerica.
Just go
picks it takes her.
I was only kidding. Totally joking. Don't
meet it. That was, that was creepy though.
Like they were, they were, they
held firm for a little while.
Then this is our policy. If you want to
leave, that's fine. This is their policy.
And they realize like
this is a serious issue.
And around the same time
this is under reported,
their website was inaccessible for
almost a whole week. Whoa. And a,
is that a d d o s a?
No,
they never said it was a denial of
service and nobody ever took her up
responsibility for it. You would think
of somebody took down bank of America,
they'd say, Yo, we did this right.
But what actually happened
is it just was not working.
And Bank of America said we're having
service issues and it was never properly,
uh, no journalists properly looked into
this. I don't know what the cause was,
but I know it did not appear to
be a, a, an attack of any kind.
It appeared to be a technical problem.
And there are some people who wondered,
is Bank of America trying to slow
what is basically run on the bag?
Cause there are a lot of people who saw
the articles about the $5 debit card
thing and like,
fuck this,
I'm just gonna move my money
out and go to another bank.
And they were trying
to do it on the right.
Nowadays a bank run doesn't look
like what you see in the movies.
It's not people running to a bank
branch and demanding their money.
It's people log on to their
bank account, click, you know,
out of Bank of America into my chase
account. Boom. Enough people did that.
The bank is no longer a solvent.
So some people wondered if they were
trying to slow that outflow until they
could figure out a policy like do we
need to say we're not going to charge the
$5 fee or you know,
and then to go conspiracy on you.
One dude even said that they're preparing,
they're testing it out to see how,
how would we stop and actual bank run
and modern times and the best way to do
it, we just shut down your
mobile banking access,
shut down your website access or slow it
to the point where it's difficult to do
stuff and you, you don't have as many
people taking out money. Oh my God,
that should be illegal. It should be.
It was never properly looked into that.
Like I said, is there any policy
in regards to that? I don't know.
Like if they claim they're
having service issues,
I don't know how much of a role of
government has, he can't check on that.
That seems like it was
definitely about that.
It's a weird coincidence of the timing.
That's what bothered me.
Like it's one thing if a bank has
an outage because that does happen,
but the timing was so perfect.
It's like if I were a big bank
and a lot of people are just, uh,
if I were just being hemorrhaged right
now, all these people withdrawing,
maybe I would turn off my website
and shouldn't that be all over CNN?
Shouldn't that be all over Fox News?
Customers demand answers and
rightly so. Right. And rightly so.
I think a western union is looking better
every day or whatever that she had a
hole in my back yard just throwing money,
check cashing places.
The whole idea money is fucking terrifying
ones and Zeros and fucking decimal
points. What is, you're like,
uh, I liked the thing about gold. How,
like when somebody hands you a gold coin,
not that I've never actually made that
much money where if somebody hands me a
gold coin, but uh, when you look at
one in a store and they hand it to you,
it has weight,
right?
And you know that like it's possible
this thing has thousands of years old and
has no rust on it. And regardless of like
what that thing is in terms of dollars,
you know that what you have is valuable.
And it same thing like jewelry is made
out of gold and silver and it's just
something like in our, in our,
uh, like little primitive brains,
we know like shiny metal that's
heavy and doesn't rust, has value.
We can turn it into a million different
things. This is money, you know? Uh,
and then dollars seem like
more and more ridiculous.
Do you know the ultimate ridiculous
theory on why gold is valuable?
What the Zacharias Hitchin theory?
I'm not knowing that Ho,
here we go down a crazy road.
The ancient Sumerian text is like this
cuneiform text that was written on clay
tablets and it's just really odd.
Ancient language from
about 6,000 years ago were,
it looks like you ever seen
like an old school nail,
like a nail on a really old building.
You don't have a purpose.
It's like triangular almost.
Yeah, exactly. It's not like
a tabletop of the spike.
It's not like that. They're,
they're more of like, like a,
like a steak look and sort
of a thing. Cause they were
mined out of, uh, you know,
they were, they were iron, they were made
out of iron, these fucking things. Uh,
she just, what was my point is Zachariah
Zachariah sit to the cuneiform so that,
anyway,
this is this weird series of lines and
it's all subject to interpretations.
It's really difficult stuff to,
to decipher.
But this one guy,
Zacharias hitching,
who's a legitimate biblical
scholar and ancient linguist,
he said that the entire thing was
about the undue knocky and that the
[inaudible] were an alien race that
created us like the engineer in the the
movie Prometheans like this was the,
this idea of the Annunaki.
There were these giants that created us
by mixing their DNA with primate DNA.
Okay.
And that all of this was so that they
could make us work for them and mine gold
because they needed gold particles to
suspend in their atmosphere to protect
them from the radiation of sounds totally
retarded that that's the answer I'm
going to give. When somebody asks me what
my religious beliefs, I'm going to say,
here's what's crazy.
This guy wrote this shit in like the
1970s and he's a legit scholar so it's
really difficult to argue with them.
Although many other legit scholars do
argue with them and completely disagree
with his,
with his translations of it.
But what his translation that what got
really weird was he wrote this in like
1970 and the two thousands, 2005 or
six or something like that, they were,
they had some sort of a
scientific symposium when
they're trying to figure out
what are there other alternative methods
of protecting people from radiation if
we lose, uh, the, uh, the, uh,
are part of our atmosphere,
like ozone layers and stuff like that.
And they came up with suspending
reflective particles in the atmosphere.
So these people back then had no idea
that 1970, they had no idea that, well,
this Zacharias hitching guys certainly
was no scientists in regards to, you know,
how to deflect radiation.
That wasn't his area of expertise.
So him coming up with this
as a translation from a
6,000 year old text that was
written on clay tablets,
right?
It's quite remarkable that they mean he
sang something that scientists figured
30,
40 years later.
And what he's saying is that reflective
particles suspended in the atmosphere
can protect you from
radiation, right? Well,
the thing about gold is gold
is unlike any other metal.
And this is not something that you
would need back in the day when you were
fucking hurting. And you
know, you had a need,
a good metal that you can make a
sword out and we can kill people.
Gold wasn't useful in that way,
but what it is useful and you could take
gold dust and the small piece of gold
can make an incredible amount
of this ultra fine dust.
And if gold has a bizarre,
almost magical properties where you
can take one piece of golden coat and
incredibly wide surface with
the most, uh, towards ductile,
it's the most ductile metal there is.
You can bang it out into this thin little
flake. Yeah, it's an amazing metal.
It's a really bizarre and amazing mental
and that it would be the perfect mental
for suspending in our atmosphere
to protect us from radiation.
And that Earth has, uh, you know, a,
a whole area where there's a lot of gold.
So these aliens came down here realize
that this is a good place for them to get
some gold out of how do you do it? I
don't want to let's make some people well,
okay, that's, it makes me, she grabbed
some monkeys, the through some DNA in him.
It's completely ridiculous.
Cowboy to add. But it's not to add
credibility to your theory. Okay.
A cowboys and aliens. Yes. You seen that?
Sure. There are there to harvest gold.
Yeah. You know? Yeah. I
don't think that helps us.
I'm being sarcastic about being
sarcastic about was looking forward to it
movie so bad.
But the idea was that that's why we still
have this thing for gold that we were
literally put on earth to mine for gold.
So we still think it's nice
connection with value. Wow.
And then we've lost completely lost all
of our memories of the Annunaki cause
this is thousands upon thousands.
What if it's less sinister than that?
And it's like they came to earth
and they're like, look guys,
we need gold for our project
and the atmosphere thing.
So you give us gold and we'll give you
stuff that you need and then you have
people suddenly realizing,
okay, Gold's money, you know?
Oh yeah. It could be that.
What's,
what's interesting about,
I don't like the idea of being an
engineered by like biologically engineered
slave.
What would the, the reason why
I lean towards that and not,
not 100% I mean,
I don't agree with it or disagree with it,
but I don't reject it as an idea simply
because of the fact that the only thing
that's like us,
his dogs,
the only thing that's like us that can
vary so widely by the way it looks is
humans. We're the only thing
that [inaudible] like a dog dogs.
Very incredibly man. You
can have Max. Wow, us. Yeah,
because they were like, we there
were designed, right. We made them,
they vary because of human
intervention and I mean maybe it's a,
what came first?
The chicken or the egg,
maybe human innovation
came and then people varied
drastically or when they were
fucking created, they made a bunch
of different versions of them.
They tried a little bit of this.
They went with like Asians
probably have little more alien in
them just to touch just a smidge.
I'm Italian.
I probably have a little more monkey,
you know, they probably, and by the way,
this is not racist to alien
to agents because it's better,
I think probably to be more evolved,
it's better to have little less monkey.
So it's actually racist against myself.
So I don't want any fucking Twitter beef
over this, but it's ridiculous. Look,
it's written. It's totally, completely
ridiculous. It's, I don't know,
and I don't believe in it, but I propose
it. Who the fuck knows? Man? We're,
we're starting to learn all sorts
of crazy shit about our past.
We're starting to learn about ancient
civilizations in it at a time where we did
not think that people were
capable of building anything.
And if they have these giant
stone structures in South
America back. No sense.
Timeline wise, that's another thing. Like,
I remember going through school and you
read the textbooks about Columbus and
all this basic shit. Not once
those textbooks are, they
mentioned, oh, by the way,
there's some random cities in
South America. Yeah. Bill, uh,
in a way that's like really doesn't
make sense at that time period.
And they're so far, I don't have
the numbers in my mind right now,
but they were so distant to everything
else that it's like we don't have any
idea of what that is. Yeah. And well not
only that, there's thousands of them,
they're finding new ones
and the jungle all the time.
I mean it was an incredible civilization
that existed just a couple thousand
years ago. The, the Mayan civilization
wasn't even that long ago.
And we know so little about what really
happened. It's, it's an an amazing,
amazing time.
I watched a great documentary on National
Geographic called decoding the Maya.
It's available.
I bought a DVD of it and it's all about
them working on the translations of a,
the different Mayan hieroglyphs
and how difficult it is and like,
like trying to decipher things and the
way they go about it and the scientific
method they use to try to figure out
what the fuck each little thing means.
And fascinating stuff.
I mean,
they had a completely different
way of writing the world.
They wrote the world in pictures and
pictures that represented sounds that you
would make and they would vary. It would
vary whether or not that sound was like,
you know,
like if you had like they would like
the way it's explained it transport can
explain it. Like if you were going
to look right, I saw aunt rose,
you would do an eyeball a saw like
saw and then you do at the insect and,
and then you would do a rose
and that would be, I saw him,
he also had human sacrifice. A lot
of it. Yeah. I read Daniel Pinch,
Pinch Beck's book. Uh, he
seems really interesting.
I read actually a,
he wouldn't get high with us.
You had on the show and we would not
get high with the I kid high with, uh,
why did you, you don't
want to be like, oh,
maybe you didn't want to get weirded out.
You don't want to be a, what's the word?
Like do it for show maybe.
I think some people also get
uncomfortable when they're high,
when they're on and they're
talking about things seriously.
They didn't want to come up with
too much dude, bro Talk. Right.
You know they're worried about
people seeing them stoned,
but I thought he's like the
psychedelic pioneer dude.
I thought he would hop right in. Yeah.
Yeah. I met him when I was in boulder.
Anthony Bordain two fisted,
like a soldier.
We took that due to the depths
of unfortunately because
it made the conversation kind of weird
because he was a little hung over from
the grammys. That motherfucker went
deep with us, respects our respect.
I got respect for you. I could tell
how he was too, cause I know it.
Unless you're getting this
shit on a regular basis that
the the there's the kind
of marijuana that's available
in southern California.
It's so potent and so awesome and
should be respected for that instead of
suppressed by this ridiculous
fucking d e a and government.
We are in so silly.
We're in a new era of prohibition.
That's one of the things that are,
it's one of things I'm going to legislate
and might not actually get it through,
but you can start putting the bills out
there. What are you going to try to do?
It has to be decriminalized. It's not
even like the main focus of my campaign,
like my thing is bill of rights and
spying on us, like ending those things.
But do you think it's possible to turn
things back and absolutely is possible
because uh,
the latest polls,
like 50% of the American people support
decriminalization and legalization,
but elected officials only
one to 2% support that.
So you have a huge disparity where these
old assholes have have to go or they
have to change their,
their a stance because it's not
going to stay like that forever.
You don't have an elected body that
believes a one thing and then 50% of your
own people believe something
entirely different that doesn't work.
And it's not much different than
when Galileo was in position.
It's really sort of along the same
lines we'd cause it grows absolutely
everywhere.
You find it by railroad tracks and you
just pulled out of the ground and it's
super nutritious.
Yeah.
And you can make clothes out of it and
you can build buildings out of it as a
bottle of whiskey. Do all that. I mean,
you could fucking fuel a car with
that shit. Really. Realistically,
you could take one acre of hemp.
It's as good as four acres of trees.
If you're trying to make paper,
it's the most ridiculous plan ever.
I'm not trying to, uh, to pander
to your show because I know,
I know you talked about this a lot,
but like we can't move forward as a
country if we're spending so much of our
resources on criminalize the something
that it's not a crime. Not only that,
something that's incredibly,
incredibly beneficial.
We're suppressing farmer's ability to
make money of farmer's ability to make
money. By the way, not off selling drugs.
We're talking about the actual plant hemp,
which is not psychoactive in any way,
shape or form. It is not what you
won't show. You can eat it. I eat,
we sell hemp protein, hemp force protein.
One of the biggest questions we get is,
am I going to Piss hot for this? I work,
you know, at a company that drug test me,
should I be like, yeah, you
can tell. It's not that.
It's nothing to do with that marijuana.
It's disgusting to terrifying.
I'm of the age where I have a lot of
friends who are like trying to get into
better positions and they're
all worried about drug testing.
It's weird because there are all these
companies are like preventing themselves
from hiring the next batch of
innovators. Yeah, of course.
Like you're hiring people who are
complete boring accountants who have never
tried anything. And I'm so offended at
this idea that no one can handle drugs.
And I,
I find that so ridiculous that just
because one person can handle it or a few
people can handle it doesn't mean I can't
handle it because drinking is one of
the worst fucking drugs there is period.
Right. I can handle it. I enjoy drinking.
There's no doubt.
You compare how your body feels the
next day between the two things. Uh,
there's no doubt.
There's no comparison.
And the idea that I would somehow or
another lose control because I've tried
something or because I enjoy
something in my off time.
It's silly if you don't give a person
enough respect as your employee that they
will go home and sit down in front of
the TV and smoke a joint when they,
when they relax at home.
Right?
You don't give them enough respect
to have that time to themselves,
to maybe smoke a little weed and chill
out when they're not riding on the
company dime then not doing.
They're not responsible for anything.
You're going to test them for that.
That's ridiculous. You, you're an asshole.
You're trying to be a slave owner.
You're not trying to be an employee.
You can't tell people what to
do when they're not at work.
It's one thing if you're on
an oil, one of those, uh,
offshore oil rigs and then
you're basically on the
job 24 hours a day because
anything can go wrong at any time.
Completely understand having
a zero tolerance policy bear,
but for some office job where you have
a large portion of your day where you're
not working,
you should be allowed to do what you want,
especially when you're using something
that is not killed a single person ever.
It's very, very, very good point
about dangerous jobs. Very good point.
It's not that we're being completely
unreasonable and you're like,
governments do that in my
life. Everywhere. No government
government, we should,
we should definitely check people
out before we let them on planes.
We should definitely test people for
drugs if they're in charge of oil rigs and
you know, even even spine,
like people think I'm uh,
I'm totally against intelligence
agencies have not, like,
there's a big role for
us to have spy agencies.
Like you want to see what these fucking
people in Afghanistan and caves are
talking about.
You want to be tapping their sat
talking about how do I make a fire?
How do we hold it in this case?
How do we get these drones to
stop dropping stuff on us? Yeah.
What's your position on drones?
So drones are really pretty awful for a
lot of the same reasons is warrantless
spine. There's not enough
accountability. Like right now,
maybe it's being used properly.
We really don't know.
But at what point does it just become
convenient for a president to say, look,
this guy has a major asshole. He's causing
us a lot of trouble with all of his,
uh, uh, let's say like down the road
somebody like Julian Assange was like,
let's just get rid of this guy,
one drone strike, he's done.
And then people will talk about it
for a couple of days and that's it.
Cause that's how the media cycle works.
You know,
people would be outraged for
a couple days and that's it.
So they take their one time, credibility
hit and they just move on. And I don't,
I don't think that's acceptable.
Again,
it's too much power for
the government to have the,
a number of civilian drones
is in or civilian casualties
because of drones is in
the thousands now. I mean
it's, it's not just a,
a couple of people accidentally die.
Also, there's an evil aspect to it.
Like it used to be if you
wanted to kill somebody,
you stabbed them with something and
it was pretty intimate, you know,
and then it's, it's been
depersonalized. That were time.
It went from that to start a ride to
sniper rifles to you drop something out of
a plane. Yeah. But even then,
you're still on top of their city.
You're looking down, you're pushing the
button, you're making a moral choice. Like
the evil I'm doing here is outweighed
by the benefit it will have of winning
this battle or winning this war.
The drone.
Some guy just goes to work
at an army base, plugs in,
like he's playing a video game, goes home
at night, mission accomplished. You know,
it's a, it's a level of separation
that is, uh, just scary.
Yeah. These civilian drones trikes
depending on who you listen to, there's,
there's a, there's a couple different
figures that they throw around,
but all of them are over a thousand
from the conservative numbers.
The conservative numbers around 1,802
and the less conservative numbers are
above 2000. But either that, I mean,
all of that, that's scary stuff.
That's like nine,
11 numbers.
I mean this is the amount of innocent
civilians that are killed because we're
going after these bad guys and these
people just have to be near him. Yeah.
It happened to me near him. Allegedly
the, there is, I agree completely.
There's something crazy about
the ability to take some random,
you know, object, some,
some created object rather and fly it
through the fucking air to another country
and it launches hell fire missiles at
people while you're controlling it with a
remote control,
like you're watching a video game.
And what's, what's so weird about
that also is like, so as a society,
we're making a choice to devote a lot of
our technological energy and definitely
taxpayer money to building better drones
because these big defense contracts get
them.
And uh,
so we're learning ways to like vaporize
16 year olds in a more efficient manner.
Basically these people who are like,
you're in some town in Afghanistan,
you have no other choices cause there's
no economy and some more lord recruits
you and you're caught up in something
that's definitely evil but you don't have
much control over necessarily.
And without being given a trial,
you're just killed one day by a
robot. Basically. That's what it is,
is a robot in the sky. I think Bill
Maher calls them sky robots. Uh,
so you're killed by this thing.
And maybe if we need to give
huge contracts to defense
companies because they
lobbied the shit out of Washington, if
that's just the way it is, no matter what,
we always have to give
them massive contracts.
Why not go back to what we were doing in
the 60s which was part of those massive
contracts. We're going to
the space program. You know,
these companies put us on the
moon instead of building drones.
Well,
let's just cleaning up the inner cities,
just strengthening our education system.
There's all sorts of jobs that
can be had that are very positive.
Instead of these jobs that all go to
the DEA and busting pot farms and these
jobs that all go to Tsa workers grabbing
people and sticking them in radiation
boxes,
they're seen.
It seems to me like we should be able
to figure out a way to distribute all
those people in a positive way back
into our economy, back into our work.
Yes. And lead police aren't
bad everywhere you go.
Like I've traveled to a lot of places
where the police actually seemed like
members of the community in small towns
where there's less pressure in small
towns and, and other countries
where the cops don't have uniforms.
So they look like judge Dredd.
Like here I've noticed the uniforms could
keep getting scarier and scarier. Uh,
it depends on the city obviously. But
you know, they seen the Cammo. Yeah.
Irvine in south Florida,
the guys have like body vests
on. It wasn't, it wasn't
Irvine. What was the, um,
the city in Orange
County, Anaheim, Anaheim,
there was a protest that was a total
joke as a total media blackout.
That Anaheim thing started to escalate.
So nothing about in the news.
I had to just Google news it,
you know,
he just gives routes
where Disneyland is bitch,
they know how to keep shitting on
the raft. Disneyland. But I mean,
they had people in camouflage
and you're like, what do you,
what is the message of
you being in camouflage?
Is that the only clothes you have?
Right?
Or are you letting me know
that you've killed people?
Are you letting me know that you're
a trained killer from overseas?
You're not looking around number
of the community keeping the piece.
Are you ready for some serious shit?
Yeah.
Why are you wearing body armor and why
do you have a fucking machine gun and why
you standing around when people were
protesting the death of, of uh, you know,
a young man was shot in the back,
the whole thing.
How about the fucking guy that shot
himself in the head in the backseat?
That was fucked up.
I don't think we ruled it a suicide.
I don't believe that for a second.
But the,
the brazen act of ruling that the suicide,
that,
that shit is completely ridiculous.
How the fuck did they get away with that?
Right. It's part of when you could
get a society that's corrupt,
you have corrupt rulings,
but the fact that people would be willing
to just listen to that and go, yeah,
wow, okay. I shouldn't have shot himself
in the head. You pull the guy over,
you arrest him and he's like,
this is it. My life's over.
I'm going to shoot myself in the head
while I'm handcuffed behind my back and
I'm a shoot myself in the temple.
Yeah.
The next few hours is going to
be inconvenient being processed,
so I'm just going to kill
myself. Yeah. I mean, no sense.
I'm going to put it up to my temple too.
Yeah.
How can you even fucking do
that? Can you even do that? Well,
what you have to be like a yoga chick.
What scares me is when these videos come
out of police just beating the shit out
of somebody for no reason and you wonder
like how many times is this happening,
where the right conditions weren't there,
where there happened to be somebody who
had the balls and the camera and the
camera to actually film it. You
know, when I was in high school,
my friend Jimmy was, uh, in, um,
there's a place called Kenmore Square in
Boston and this is back when they had,
um, they had dudes who would, uh,
put cardboard down on the street
and they would break dance. Yeah,
I used to do that. Remember that
ship? It was really popular. Well,
there was break dancers and these
punkers, there was like a, a bar there.
There's so, there's like these
punk people and these breakdowns.
People got into a fucking crazy bra and
the cops come and showed up and patty
wagons and he said he had
never seen anything like it.
Dudes were just swinging those bats and
cow racking people in the head because
there's no video, there's
no, no one's monitoring them.
He said they would crack people in the
head. He goes, the sound was so sickening.
And then they would take their head and
slam it into the patty wagon before they
go in.
Everyone just slam their fucking head
into the metal and then toss them in.
He said it was so disturbing that
like watching it and they're like,
he never looked at cops
the same way again.
Just watching them just get cracked in
the head by bats and then slam their head
into the metal and then push them in
because they were involved in a big brawl.
Right.
And that was back when people had brawls
where they didn't shoot each other.
They just beat each other up.
Like those don't exist anymore.
Allegedly.
Some of those occupy protesters,
they like what handcuffed them in a way
that's painful using the plastic cuffs
and they show them all into vans and,
uh, they were in there for so long,
they're forced to urinate on each other.
Even like they were denied access to a
bathroom when they asked for one. And uh,
you,
you hear about this all the time,
like where they're doing the handcuffs
so hard that people are screaming from
going to be like fixed, you know, and
they just don't care. It's so sick.
That's not, that's not, uh, that's
not what America is about. You know,
we have the freedom of protest.
So when I see people protesting,
I'm actually kind of excited because it
means that people are engaging again.
You know, they're like, okay,
I care about this issue.
I'm going to tell you what I think
of it. That's a good thing. Uh,
having debate and discussion, that's,
that's a sign of life, you know,
and they're treating it like it's this
threat to our existence in a threat to
national security.
It's super creepy.
One of the creepy things was a,
we had Jamie Kilstein on who's been a
very involved in the occupy process from
the beginning, and he was talking to me
about cops that have products, no cops,
police officer, police officers that
have infiltrated and they pretend yeah.
To be, uh, yeah, the agent
provocateurs. Yeah. That,
that strikes me is one of the most fucked
up things also that you get paid for
that public protest. It's peaceful
and isn't harming the community.
Then you have exactly you of taxpayer
money going into turning this into a
violent death
orderly thing.
It should be.
So you can bust people who would not
have been an issue in the first place.
It'd be treason. Yeah. It
should be complete treason.
If you find out that someone has ever
done that and they have done that,
it should be absolutely treasonous.
You should go to jail. You have,
you fucked up the,
the,
the civil discourse of this situation
that is against the Sim, the community,
your, your, you are, your
actions are undermining the
piece of the community. Yeah.
You should go to jail.
They should all in the fact that it just,
we're just allowed that and we just
sort of accept that that level of,
of not, not just incompetence on
the part but, but real corruption.
It's not in competence. It's
institutional. Like you said,
it's not the people at the
bottom level who are the problem.
Somebody up top is saying,
look,
you better rough these protesters up
cause we don't want them coming back next
weekend and they're so
stupid. This is the, this,
the incompetence is that this is the only
way they feel like they can handle it
and let's even stupid or is this
what's going to lead to bigger protest?
Of course, because the
denial of, of, of equality,
the fact that they won't consider these,
that these people are a
part of the community.
When the community is having this
much problem with your action,
you're doing something wrong.
There's something wrong, there's an,
then there's an injustice. It's not an
unreasonable, ridiculous thing. Like,
you know,
some crazy person's saying,
you stole all my money from
the golden giant. No, you're,
you're talking like real sense and
deciding and you're being ignored.
And when that happens, it's, it's right
to protest. It's American to protest.
It's patriotic to protest.
It shows that you're,
you're stepping outside of
the box to say, hey, I am one.
I want to be counted amongst the people
that think there's something wrong with
this. That's what America
is supposed to be all about.
So the problem with Americans,
it's run by an American's.
It's run by people who are not.
I have a lot of people who believe that
nine 11 was like the opportunity of a
lifetime. Yeah. You know,
get a better, get a better
position within the government,
make a shitload of money
on these crazy contracts,
doing spying programs and putting body
scanners and airports and all this stuff.
A lot of people made money off of this
and I consider that quite unamerican to
profit off of a tragedy like
that and in such a blatant way.
You know what was quite unamerican have
Dick Cheney as a vice president. Yeah.
How crazy is that?
To have this guy who was a vice president
who used to be the CEO of a company
that fixes shit after you book? Well, the
whole thing there, if we weren't corrupt,
we should have just said, okay great.
You're a CEO of Halliburton, no big deal,
but no government contracts
while you're in office.
We're not sending a penny to Halliburton
cause it's a total conflict of interest.
You know,
I don't understand why government gets
away with things that in the financial
sector would just be considered ludicrous.
Insider trading.
Exactly thing much less
horrible than that. Yeah.
It just knew that a company was going
to fold and you sold your stock. Yep.
That seems like a smart business move,
but that's completely and totally illegal.
If this motherfucker had the,
the access to this entire giant business
that rebuild things after you bought
and he was the guy running it. Yeah.
And then he gives them contracts.
No bid contracts for billions
and billions of dollars.
Dan is so blatant and in your face,
it's so crazy. It's kind of like,
it's like what are you going
to do about it? You know,
the media is not going to cover it all
that much and we know you're not going to
protest because he might get
the shit kicked out of you.
So what are you gonna do about it?
We're just gonna do it anyway. Shit.
That's totally an American. Yeah,
that's totally UNAMERICAN. Does anybody,
does Alpha brain make you curse more?
Just being
here with us the other day I saw the
creepiest thing ever in Burbank and I
immediately raised a really the creepiest
thing ever. You want to clarify that?
It was pretty creepy and then
I found a video of it. Yeah.
I've been like searching to see if
anyone else saw it. What was that?
Check this out,
but just tell me what it was.
It's a tons of tanks is going
through on the train track.
Oh my readers,
my readers have sent me that stuff.
Different videos from different parts
of the country. Yeah. It's creepy.
It could totally be like just the normal,
uh,
it's coming off of a factory line
has to be shipped somewhere else.
You were going to send me something
like cats, butthole or something.
But isn't it weird that we're now at
the point where our government really is
doing so many terrible things that we
see tanks and our first thought is,
are they going to use these against us?
Can you imagine that?
Can you imagine a World War II? Like
you see a line of tanks? You'd be like,
hell yeah. You won't be like, I
hope they don't use this against us.
The real problem is when they
don't need drivers. Yeah.
And when you get us the real
problem [inaudible] man drowns.
When you have a few people running
these fucking things by remote control,
they can, they can take over
cities and do a lot of shit.
That's impossible to do when you don't
have an evil cunt behind the switch.
But if they just have a few dudes work
in somewhere pushing all the buttons for
these fucking things, you watched
the new total recall, hell no sun.
They have the synthetic where they just
turn that thing on and they all go out
and I think we're going to fuck things
up way before that ever happens.
Hopefully. But this,
this is disturbing man.
Knowing this is drones and knowing all
the thousands of people that have died
that were totally innocent
because the drones, no,
the fact that no one seems to have a
problem with that because we don't know
those little brown people. We
don't know them. Yeah, I'm not,
I'm not afraid of the technology. Like
it's the technology is the technology.
You can never turn it back.
Like drones are now a part of warfare.
That's the way it goes.
Yeah.
The problem I have is a total lack of
accountability. Who are these people?
Why are they being targeted?
Did they deserve to be killed or could
they have been detained and questioned?
Not only that,
given a trial,
these people that are deciding who to go
after and who not to go after and what
is your motivation and what ties
do you have to have the burden,
what times do you have to, how much
money, how much money do you make?
One of those missiles goes off somebody,
you know,
what does a contract for a
hundred new missiles worth?
Is it worth a lot because it seems like
a good motivation to invade someplace
where there's nobody paying
attention to anyways, fuck him up.
Just fucking get rid of some missiles.
It's crazy.
It's crazy that people could
try to make money doing that,
but there's so much money in doing that.
You have to consider it.
Look at Afghanistan, it's like, uh,
I was talking to somebody about this.
Our whole policy is like,
okay,
we can send them some school supplies
and occupied their country with our
military forces for a few years and
then they're going to have democracy.
It's just going to spring up because
those people are like literally a thousand
years behind where we are literally like,
it's like the,
it's like tattoo in and star wars.
Like they're not there yet.
There are certain bridges
that need to be built.
You don't just go from like localized
warlords and this creepy desert that has
like insane looking spiders. Actually
that's an Iraq. They have camel spiders.
They're fed people. Those on
fear factor. Yeah, that's,
I don't like the idea
that they eat him alive.
Camel spiders should be eating people,
not the other way around.
They're creepy looking alien bugs.
They were gigantic.
They would fit right in starship
troopers. Yeah. Yeah. But anyway,
like that part of the world is
not ready for like three years.
Going from localized warlords to
functioning democracy. We can pull out,
we're done. It's just an to happen.
How far behind it really, truly is.
I remember McCain referring it to it.
Mccain was debating Obama
and he was saying like,
he doesn't understand what he's talking
about when you're talking about invading
Afghanistan. Afghanistan has
run the same way it was when,
you know the people who were on horseback,
it was like Alexander the Great, yeah,
yeah. I just saw a headline today. Uh,
the Taliban beheaded a bunch of people
and their crime was going to a party that
was mixed sex.
So there are men and women listening to
music together and drinking together.
Boom. I mean, oh my God,
that's how far behind they are.
They are so willing to take it
to the next level like that.
That is how you really control people.
I mean that you chop their fucking heads
off in the middle of the streets and
nobody does shit. And what does
that do? It creates a, yeah,
it chills that, that's not gonna
happen again. But we know that that's,
and that's what's
really disturbing about human nature.
And then in 2012 we have direct evidence
that people who are in positions of
power are capable of doing
something that fucked up.
And if you really believe
that people are all the same,
the only differences we have different
cultures and different environments and
different biological, you know,
makeups and different ways we look.
But essentially people are equal.
Well,
in 2012 people are cutting
people's heads off for nonsense.
That's what people in
power are capable of doing.
And we've got a look honestly and
realistically about the people that are in
power right here.
Because just because you could drive a
Saab and go to Starbucks and get Wifi at
work, just because all that's going on
doesn't mean you're not living in a den of
monster. And not only that, just
because you have those good things,
you have a safe town and you have
Starbucks and like a level of prosperity
that's really pretty good. You don't
wanna let that go. It's awesome. Yeah.
And addressing all the bad stuff that's
happening isn't going to take that away
from you.
It'll actually give you more of it because
it's less money will be going to this
bullshit.
More money will be going into programs
that will keep your town safe and clean.
When we think about America,
we think about all the good things about
America and not only will none of that
change,
it will all be enhanced because that more
people will be providing more positive
things into the city instead of our
cities and our countries and our states
being governed by this giant fucking
monster that goes overseas and blow shit
up. Instead of that, all of the tax money,
all of the resources go to building shit,
go to building shit within here,
this country making this place better,
cleaning up all the bullshit that all
these fucking corporations have left
behind in terms of toxic waste poisoning
and figure out how to manage nuclear
waste to fix all of it here though all
of it to this nonsense where the our,
our whole economy is based
on fucking people out of
their shit and another place.
That's craziness.
It's maybe you should run also fuck fan.
I would love to hear like a Mitt Romney
or somebody say basically that we need
to then I need to end outsourcing.
We bring these jobs home.
I will never be a part of this system
because this system is bullshit to me.
This system is like,
you might as well go to the rocky horror
picture show and pretend because you're
singing along that you're actually in
the movie because you're not really
changing what's going to happen.
You're, you're not really a part of it.
You're not.
It's this system is completely fucked
sideways with corruption and to for you to
jump in and try to right the ship from the
inside. But man, good luck to you. I'm,
I'm in your corner,
Dude.
You're going to try to do it and you're
going to run for Congress and I, I'm,
I'm wanting to support you and I want
you to win and I want you to get into the
positions where you can actually make
some change, but to, in order to do that,
man,
that has to be literally your whole life.
That has to be your whole life just
to correct the work of some clients.
Instead of telling the
cons to stop being cuts,
just just get your own shit together.
The people that are in the
upper positions of power,
that must be fucking creepy,
paranoid and depressed and weirded out
and on Colona Pan and all kinds of other
cooking weird drugs to get you through
your day and Xanax and Ambien to go to
sleep at night.
Do you know how many successful wealthy
people in business I know that are
addicted to Ambien?
They're popping that shit every night
to try to get some sleep because they
can't because they're crazy because
they're dealing with all kinds of nonsense
all day and fuckery a foot
every step of the way, and they,
they literally can't even fucking sleep.
They can't relax.
And everybody goes through this
existential crisis where you're like,
what the fuck is this all about?
But there's no answer.
So you'd go buy new Jaguar,
there's no answer.
So you get a new membership to
the country club and now you're,
now you're living behind the
coming. Oh. I was like, no,
it's great in your mood or
Bob and you just keep pushing.
I think a lot of it's a proxy for
not getting sex too. Yeah. Fuck yeah.
A lot of these dudes in the senator
just old and like pro despite hurt me,
but probably can't get it up anymore.
Actually. They could probably get it up,
but now if I add,
but point is they're not what they used
to be and instead of pulling all these
girls they used to pull,
they have to feel so of veer,
veer aisle by passing this shit. That is
ridiculous. Like just totalitarian stuff.
I think a small part of it is like if
you're getting sex regularly and you have
a balanced life that also involves like
friends and family and doing stuff that
has nothing to do with politics or with
building drones or any of that stuff,
why would you even be in favor of
these things? You're not going to be,
you're not going to be in that direction
of let's start a war to make some money
or let's take away rights just
to be on the safe side. You know?
You're not going to think that way.
Yeah,
that's a very good point as well.
If you're operating from a position of
comfort and power and empowerment, you're,
you're,
you feel yourself that you're doing
what you should be doing and you're very
confident about everything. You're not
going to try to suppress or other people.
And that's the problem
with the old people.
A lot of old people want to suppress
young people. It's very common.
They see people coming up and
they shit on them. You know,
I remember that from the, the comedy
days, you know, the, the older comedians,
there was two types of older comedians.
There was a really cool encouraging guys
who would uh, you know, tell you, hey,
you got to write more.
You know,
you should like go to his much on stage
as you can get the better and give you
good advice and good luck man. If
you ever have questions, I'm here.
And those guys are great. You
know those guys like they, they,
you meet a guy like that,
that like a life raft.
But then there's other guys that just
see coming up and they just want to push
it down and shit on you. We want to hold
you in place and they act like they can.
This guy, I don't want them working
with me. He says, fuck too much.
She breaks the fuck meter. Like why
you creepy Dick then? But that's a,
that's the same.
It's just crabs in a bucket.
They're just trying to hold people down.
Yeah.
And when you get to a position where
you're a guy like that where your guy like
Newt Gingrich and they go, hey
man, boxers or briefs you go by,
what kind of idiotic question is that
you think I'm not going to answer.
What are you stupid?
You know?
And then he'd just berate some poor kid
who just asked you a cute question about
your underwear. I think that says
something about your character too.
So literally it does.
It says something about you being a bully.
Like Watch your bench.
I'm talking about like boxers or briefs.
Yeah.
But yeah,
totally like that response to reporter
a Mitt Romney did something similar.
He was in Colorado and a TV report
or not even like a random person.
A TV reporter asked him about
something about marijuana policy,
which in a state like Colorado where
it's a big part of their economy is not a
crazy question and he was like pissed
that it was asked and you know,
didn't want to address
it. No, not only that,
there's a terrible defining video where
there's a patient who has some sort of
debilitating disease and
he's in a wheelchair and he
asked Mitt Romney what his
stances on medical marijuana. It's just
because it helps him. It helps him eat.
It helps.
It alleviates his pain and symptoms.
A lot of them he's telling Mitt Romney
that he benefits from this. Well,
I'm against it. I'm against medical
marijuana. I don't know what to tell Ya.
I'm against it. Just like no compassion,
no real connection with this person.
And to me it's such a telling
video of who Mitt Romney really is.
He is a guy who is willing to play
the role of the puppet to 80 people.
Never varied from the
v vary from the script.
He's stuck on the policy line.
It's so scary. It's terrifying.
It's not a real person. He
said, he doesn't even know
what the fuck he's a Mormon.
Stop. Just don alone. That that's
a can of worms. It's crazy.
I can't believe at a 314 million people,
that's our current population at the best
we can come up with is Obama who has a
record now of promoting things that the
Bush administration would not have even
done.
Like there is a former Bush administration
official said that NDA was something
that their administration would not
have tried and would not have even found
acceptable. And so you have Obama doing
these things so we know where he stands.
Let me have Mitt Romney and those are our
two best choices out of all the talent
and energy in this country. That's what we
were. And the, the answer is, of course,
those aren't our best choices.
Those are the people who were put forward.
You know, Mitt Romney, I had no part in
him becoming, uh, you know, our pick,
most people didn't have a say in that
and it just happened. And I mean,
there were better choices out there and
they weren't given enough attention.
Well,
the Ron Paul issue was the,
the greatest issue when you want to talk
about someone who has rallied behind by
so many different people.
And Ron Paul himself is a,
a radical Christian and in fact it doesn't
even support the theory of evolution.
It doesn't bother me cause he leaves
it up church, he leaves the church,
he leaves it there.
When it's influencing policy,
then I have to look at all the other
and when you want to infringe upon other
people's rights and yet you believe in
some wackiness that has to be brought
into the equation now as long as
you keep it to yourself, we're cool.
As long as you don't fuck with
people. And you really go, by the way,
this country was initially
founded a separation,
a true separation of church and state
because people were coming here because
they face religious persecution in
other lands and they said, listen,
let's just work it out. So we keep that
shit out of this. Agree. Yep. Yeah.
Founded our founding documents.
We're still beautiful like the
bill and the bill of rights.
Like now you see contracts like the terms
of use on iTunes or whatever and it's
like difficult to get
through cause it's so long.
The bill of rights threatened so you
could be like a 15 year and understand it
perfectly with no legal background.
So simple like you have a right to the
freedom of speech and peaceful assembly.
Now these are rights.
You have them,
we're not going to bury it
and some kind of legal lees.
The the the only problem that I
ever have with someone who is in a,
we call it a cult or a religion
or anything like that, like,
like being a Mormon is that
you're so committed to it.
It's not that I don't think Mormonism
can help you and make you a better person
because like I said, I know they're
really nice people that are Mormons.
It's just if you're willing to believe
that, what else do you believe? Right?
What else? What do, how much is
that going to affect your choices?
What kind of weird apocalyptic shit
should somebody put into your head?
If you really truly do believe that a
14 year old boy from 1820 found golden
tablets that contain the loss work of
Jesus and that the American Indians were
actually a tribe that came
here from Israel. Right.
And the other original Israelites,
like not a lot of,
not a lot of evidence for that.
Well,
not a lot of 14 year old kids
in are completely full of shit.
And once I start talking about angels
dropping off packages of gold and then
taking them away before the people could
come and read them and they had a magic
stones to look at them with like
this isn't even well-written. Yeah.
It's like this is crazy if that,
if someone had tried to say that today,
there's no way he would listen to them.
If a guy came to me today and said,
listen, maybe the definition
of craziness exactly you would,
but because it's old people go,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But back then it was real. If it happened
today, what would you do? You would say,
well,
there's 14 year old kid is obviously full
of shit on the miracles in the Bible.
It's like,
where did all this stuff go?
Like it happened all the time
back then and now it's like, yeah,
the real problem with board, the miracles
have happened. By the way, that dude,
a captain Sally, that was a miracle.
Like that'll probably be in our,
whatever we have is a bible
like 2000 years from now,
they'll mention that the skillful,
skillful landing,
skillful but also a brilliant job kind
of water kind of a miracle. You think so?
Well and the sense that uh,
you have a plane crash and like,
uh, like the media covers it in
such a negative way for so long.
And this one was like, just not what
you see. So I think it was a miracle,
like in the sense that, uh, maybe
it was just a skillful landing.
I don't know what the odds are, is a
man who became a fucking saved people.
He manned up,
he did what?
He's an expert pilot and he did what
he was trained to do in that situation.
He did it perfectly and he handled
himself under pressure in heroic fashion.
I don't think you should
say that's a miracle.
I think that's a man with
character that should be admired.
I don't think there's
anything miraculous about it.
I think it was training and long,
long hours in the job and, and, and,
and the expert ability
to handle an airplane.
And he just did it in a perfect way
where some people would have fucking
panicked and fell apart and
killed everybody on that plane.
That's a lot of people. I
Dunno, I'm sticking with
miracle. I think when it gets,
when it gets a pass down
the line enough times,
it's going to be that like Jesus's
hands slowly glided that thing down.
It's the water.
It's probably already there.
Maybe there's someone who was on the
plane who was praying that's taking full
credit for maybe it was
one of the horrible things
about the Colorado thing was
the guy who was claiming that the reason
why he was spared and all these other
people including young children
were killed, is that, uh, he was,
uh, spare to, to let people know
how great God is. Crazy people suck.
They suck man.
As,
and especially when you realize that it's
probably some really cool people that
got shot and this asshole know,
thinks that the reason why they got
shot and he didn't is because he was
thinking the right things. And he
was, uh, hoping to God that he could,
he could spread God's word like,
come on man.
How about you got lucky and it's a shame
that this cunt killed all these people.
How about that?
Yeah.
Or like I won the football
game because I prayed to Jesus.
What about the like millions of people
killed and all these different countries.
It's just sort of were none of
them praying, you know, like,
and yet the did the outcome of your
football match is being divinely decided,
you know, it's so creepy that
that doesn't drive everyone nuts.
It's so Korean kind of how I kind of
hope for uh, sorry to cut you off.
I kind of hope for like some kind of alien
invasion, not even an alien invasion.
Just I hope that one day NASA comes out
and says, by the way, they're aliens.
Like they might come here,
they might not,
but we found out their alien somewhere
and they had been monitoring us.
Everything we do,
just the fact they're aliens,
then it's like we all have to come
together as a people because we're now one
planet and we have to defend against
these other things so we can't get caught
up in bullshit. Like what is your old
book say versus Mild Book, you know?
Yeah. We will have to deal with reality
as it actually exists right now.
What are our resources? How can we defend
ourselves if we can? Exactly. You know,
the most compelling idea about alien life.
To me it was an alien that that
alien consciousness is creativity.
And that it's creating our society by
planting the seed of creativity in the
modern animal,
the modern monkey animal,
and forcing it to eventually pursue
it's doom and that they, it has to,
it is absolutely compelled
to fuck with manner,
to the point where it seals its own
doom. Wow. And then it's like a,
a builtin program in us.
And that it's a design.
That's how you blow up planets.
That's how you fuck with
planets along method. It just
inject creativity and, and,
and, and uh, the need for constant
innovation, bigger, better things.
And eventually they just blow the whole
thing sky high. It's an inevitable,
it's an unavoidable, awful and beautiful
at the same time. Well, I mean it's,
it all comes from our desire to
understand our surroundings better and our
desire to improve.
But why is that?
If we ultimately are temporary being shit
and we stop at a certain point and say,
all we need is food and all we need is
a comfort and let's enjoy our comradery.
While we're here and get
through this thing in a very,
very healthy and spiritual way, but
we're like, nope, not interested in that.
Interested in a bigger fucking TV and
I want some pills and make me sleep at
night and is there a way I can
get the Internet on my glasses?
I want to look through my fucking
glasses and read my email.
I don't want to ever know
where any direction is.
I want my car to drive me Google glasses,
I want my phone to have
a million photos of it
on it.
We were in some weird weird cycle
where it's like you've seen runner,
right?
Yeah.
So there are program. Tony lived for
four years, then they die. So they know.
I mean,
they're upset about that,
but also it forces you to be in
the present and that's what we are.
You don't know.
You're not going to be dead within
four years or what's the difference?
What's the difference between four
years or 40 years, you know? Right.
You're going to be dead soon and you have
these memories in your past that have
been implanted in a sense.
Like, I mean you've had,
you have real memories
of what you've done,
but at the end of the day it's all your
perception was that like the memory is
kind of like this false,
it's take this false security like okay,
I've done a lot of cool shit in the past
so I can just ride for a little while
and not do anything.
But really you can't do that cause you
don't know how much time you have left.
Well not only that, then you become
a fat fuck and a loser. Yeah.
Cause that's what happens to
people when they give up on trying.
They get fat and they get stupid and
they quit and they just lay around and do
nothing until they die. That's
someone who's not enjoying
their life. They've lit,
rested on their laurels. It's
um, it's weird to be temporary.
So weird feeling.
We don't like it.
That's why religion exists
exists in the first place.
It's almost like a scaffolding to
sort of get us through it while we're
constructing some new level
of consciousness. It's like,
let me just give you some shit to think
about this. What's going to happen.
The the really promising feeling that
you get from psychedelic drugs is that
what you experience is so stupendously
alien to what you experience on an
everyday day to day basis that it
gives you hope for some really complex
structure to the universe
that's unavailable to you
when you're in a straight
and normal a form and
state of consciousness.
And that there might be chemical doorways
to different dimensions and chemical
doorways to different experiences.
And that's essentially what your whole
neuro chemistry and your whole life is
based on your series of chemicals,
adrenaline when Shit goes wrong
and you need to fight or flight.
You know Sarah Tonin when
you have babies and delve,
I mean when you see people that you love
and you'd go outside and it's sunny and
I mean there's a,
there's all sorts of chemical releases
that are constantly going on that bring
you to altered states of consciousness.
And we know that the brain produces
some very extreme psychedelic chemicals.
So it just stands to
reason to me that this,
this idea that the only thing that's
real is some shit that you can touch with
your hands.
And that this dimension and this
experience is the only thing that's real
because it's what we're conscious of and
what we're involved in right now. I say,
I say no fucking way.
I say it's much more likely that this
thing is way more complicated than we can
even imagine.
And that we are silly little ants
walking around on a dog's ass trying to
describe the universe.
Of course it would be much better
if I didn't fuck up that last word.
I think it's weird that
like old societies, uh,
the people that they look to for advice
and for counsel or like Shamans who knew
the most about taking
these kinds of journeys.
And also they had an ancient Greece.
They supposedly had the oracle and
they were, from what I understand,
under the influence of some
kind of psychedelic drug,
which helped them come up with
their prophecies or whatever. Uh,
so this is where people look
to and today our leaders,
the people who know the least about these
things, like a guy like Paul Ryan
and claims that he's never smoked,
never smoked pot. He says that's what
somebody, somebody sent me a link to it.
It didn't read the whole article,
but I think you said it was in Gq.
He claims he's never smoked pot.
He's a silly bitch. If that's true.
It's one of two things, right? We
were talking about us before the show.
Either he's a Dork and you don't want
him to be president either he's a liar,
he's a tool or he's a liar. Yeah.
Most people have either thought about,
well I know actually I should say that
I know a lot of people that haven't
because they grew up with families where
the father had a problem or the mother
had a problem or both.
I have seen that and uh,
I've seen people who have become very
successful and are adamant against any
form of drug.
They have never had a drop of alcohol,
they have never had marijuana.
And I respect them greatly for that choice
because what that choice is for them
is that they don't want to go down the
path that they have seen their own loved
ones go down. So those things
are the enemy, those substances,
although maybe they can handle it
and maybe they couldn't get to them,
those substances are weak
and those are the right.
Well those are the respect that those
are like some of the guys who run these
rehab centers,
they were once alcoholics,
so they were once drug addicts and
they had the worst experience possible.
So then they're like, I don't want
anybody else to go through this.
Maybe some people can handle it
better than you did. You know,
just cause you fucked up your life.
So important doesn't mean that nobody
else can enjoy like a couple of beers and
they're out on a date or like out of
fundraiser or something, you know?
I mean there's people that
can't handle anything.
They can't handle any social situation.
They stammer, they fucking panic.
Their character shows,
you know,
people's character can show
in psychedelic experiences,
just like you can show in a social
experience. You know, there's, um,
one of the things that happens when
someone is first learning. Jujitsu is a,
the first time you get tapped.
It's a very humiliating feeling
when you have to give up. It's very,
it made you feel angry.
It feels very personal and it takes a
very strong person to get through that.
And it's just the very beginning of
Jujitsu, which is the hardest part.
When you get tapped, what does that mean?
Like the guy you have doubt give up. No,
no, no. The, Oh, you and
apoe coal or an arm bar.
Physically tap the path
to let them know you quit.
You quit because they're
going to kill you. You,
if the guy has your back and he's
choking you and you're tapping,
you're essentially admitting that he's
about to put you unconscious with that
choke and you're giving up. So you're
doing the olive garden basically.
That's not quitting or you doing,
you're doing the olive garden.
The a seven times it did the
olive garden, the safe word. Oh,
the say for it.
That's why I forgot we had admitted that
or we came up with that earlier. No,
it's the tapping out as the second point.
I understand what you were saying.
I'm like, is he involved in this
off guard and prank as well? Yeah,
that's our safe word.
It means that's what you do,
but it's very emotional for a lot of,
a lot of guys,
especially when they first start doing it,
it really freaks them out.
They don't like it at all.
I've had guys that like the first time
they've ever done Jujitsu and you see
them hyperventilate,
like a guy gets on top of them and
then they panic because they think that
they're about to get God and they've never
had that happen to them before. Right.
Once it happens to a few times,
once you do it a bunch of times and
then you get used to doing it to other
people,
then it becomes accepted
normal part of your everyday life and
you're not terrified of the struggle.
The struggle becomes a straw.
It's just becomes reality.
It becomes a part of reality instead
of something you're absolutely,
completely terrified of. So in getting
through that, you develop some character.
He developed some of the ability to
overcome adversity and you develop the
ability to overcome very
uncomfortable moments,
but you don't have to do
it just through Jujitsu.
You can do that shit through yoga. You
know, Yoga, yoga sounds ridiculous,
but yoga positions are really
fucking hard to hold, man.
And if you give up in the middle of the
position, you feel like a bitch, you know,
you feel like it. All right, I'm going
to go back to it. And then you'll try it.
Hold it again. But you, you gave up,
you could have hung in there and
you could have waited until the,
the lady says next she can do it.
How come you can't do it? Right?
You can't do it because you haven't
pushed yourself to the position where you
can do it. And once you do push
yourself, when then you can do it.
Then you have this wave of
accomplishment and it's feeling and this
understanding like, oh,
it's difficult to do shit.
Like everything doesn't come easy and
the thing that companies, they come easy,
they aren't, they aren't shit.
The things that you really enjoy,
the things that are really fucking hard
to do and unfortunately we have a lot of
people that are running shit that
don't have control of their character.
They have not done difficult things.
They have not tested their ego.
They have not broken there will,
they have not been broken and training.
They have not developed a real character.
What they've developed is a sort of a
fake personality that they have devised
that society wants and will accept.
So they're saying all the right things
because those right things make people
think I like you Mike.
You're a good Christian and you hold
that milk like a 1950s commercial.
You know what I mean? They
become something that think
people would like to hear.
We need an economy where a man gets
credit for starting his own business.
You did build it yourself.
I mean built your minimum wage job
all by herself. Is that guy, what is,
what is he doing?
Is he being dizzy or aware of who he is?
Because I don't really think you can
be aware of who you are unless you have
some form of a transcendent experience.
That transcendent experience could be a
fucking vision quest where you hike to
the top of Mount Everest or
death experiences. A lot of
people change after that.
They're like, oh this shit, this shit
really doesn't matter. They certainly do.
They certainly do perspective wise.
And they also do because the,
the release of endogenous psychedelic
chemicals that happen in the near death
experience,
people in near death experiences have
some really fucking vivid hallucinations
that um, by the way, a mirror,
the ones where they've injected
people with dimethyltryptamine,
which is a chemical that your brain
produces when you're dreaming.
So they've injected people
with dimethyltryptamine and
they have also have these
intense psychedelic experiences that
were very similar to the experiences of
people that people had during
near death experiences.
What people saw the bright light and
they went through the tunnel and they cut
to another side and all of
that shit mirrors and mimics
the experiences that our
rep, you could replicate them
with psychedelic chemicals
that the brain makes.
So all of it to that.
There's a lot of different things that
can happen to a person where they get a
fresh perspective and in
near death experiences.
One of them for a variety of reasons,
just so you know, perspective,
the fact that it was almost over,
man, maybe I need to rethink my life.
Not even just for the, the high
that you get from those chemicals,
flooding your brain, but both,
both, both of them together.
But I think you need to do something
in life, man. People need a quest.
They need a vision.
They need,
they need something that tests their
character and in a way that doesn't hurt
other people. And if it, you know,
even if you heard, well, you know,
you mean you heard of the people
through competition. That's,
that's sort of a voluntary thing.
And I'll give you engage in
martial arts competition.
You're going to hurt people,
but they're going to hurt you too.
But you will also grow.
And then you will also grow from it
because it's so fucking difficult and the
body can heal and it's worth it as
in terms of what it can do for your
character.
Can you develop your character in ways
that are really unavailable for people
who are not tested?
And it doesn't mean tested
necessarily tested physically.
They can be tested mentally.
It can be a meditation thing.
It could be getting over, you know,
uh, various aspects of, of, of uh,
understanding of your yourself,
exploring the mind.
It can be a bunch of different things,
but you gotta be tested in this fucking
life, like real legitimately tested.
You can't just jump into a fucking
party of Douche bags that are currently
running shit and act like
they want you to act.
Then all of a sudden you're some position
of power and you're some weird Mitt
Romney care probably doesn't
even know who the fuck he is.
Well,
it sounds how to make money.
It's like those people who
are like Xda and they're like,
they come out against drugs and all this
shit and you're like, yeah. Too Bad.
You weren't able to speak up when
you were actually in that position.
He come out for drugs and come out
illegal. We against what's happening.
And then you're like,
too bad you couldn't say a single word
about that while you were actually in
that position deciding policy.
You know
Michael Rupert is a,
a friend of the show and he's been on
and a couple of times and Michael Rupert
was a cop in the 1980s during
the whole Iran Contra affair,
went on television,
exposed the CIA selling drugs in south
central Los Angeles and he exposed the
whole thing.
And you know,
this is a guy who was a fucking former
narcotics officer and he saw them selling
it and it was like, you know
what? Fuck this. This is
crazy. I'm out of here. And he,
he did do what he should
do. William Binney, right?
Like William Benny. Exactly.
But much like William Benny.
So his life is in chaos since then,
you know, I mean, it's uh, to,
to run around like this guy,
this port mathematician and get guns.
Putting your face for what exactly?
For what?
For exposing something that is
like mean this guy is a pain.
Yeah. For exposing something that is
really destructive to the constitution.
And trap wire. Let's talk about
that. Uh, I know this is rude,
but can I do another Pittsburgh? Oh yeah.
You're an elemental. We got five minutes,
Joe. We've got a little baby bladder. I
need to get to trap wire. Can you hold,
can you hold it, hold it.
Hold trap wire for people.
Because this is apparently the
longest podcast we've ever done.
We only have five minutes. Yep.
Shit. Trap wire, uh, came out
of, so wiki leaks and one of their
latest batches of emails has a bunch of
correspondence within this
company called Strat for,
which is a private intelligence firm.
It's kind of like the
privatized version of the CIA.
And I think the CIA would be offended
by that comparison because Strikeforce
seems a lot less competent,
uh, than the CIA.
But straight forwards just this
private intelligence company,
they gather information, uh, for a variety
of clients like private corporations.
I think coca cola has used them before.
Just gather information on whatever they
need. Uh, don't hold me to Coca Cola,
but I'm pretty certain they've used them.
They have big clients,
big fortune 500 companies, and they
get data and do all this stuff anyway.
And the emails that the strap for
executives are sending back and forth.
A lot of confidential stuff was revealed
about all kinds of things that the
public is not supposed to know about.
And one of those was a company
called trap wire, which, uh,
developed a computer algorithm that
basically tracks people using public
surveillance cameras. That's
the best way to describe it. Uh,
using things like gait
recognition, the way you walk, uh,
it can potentially recognize you from
one spot to the next and it can flag you
for suspicious behavior, but you don't
know what the suspicious behaviors are.
They think it can be something like just
taking photographs of a landmark that
flags you into the system or a signaling
for your family to come over so that
they can take a photo with you,
things like that.
Or just loitering in an area for too long.
So this computer program,
it's not a person with judgment.
This computer algorithm decides you're
suspicious individual and a threat,
and then puts you into their
system and profiles you.
And then when you go somewhere else,
like let's say you're initially flagged
somewhere in the state of Texas,
that a couple months later
you're on vacation in New York,
one of the subway cameras in New York.
Can we identify you and build
a file of where you've been,
where you know and predict your behavior,
possibly even predict where you might
go next based on where you've been.
Just another way that government,
uh,
and private corporations might be tracking
people without their approval. I mean,
this is a clear violation of the fourth
amendment. We can't stop this podcast,
Brian, we have to talk about those. Let's
stop it and start it again until you get
eight minutes.
So I think you,
can I give you a fake buffer just because
I notice you and don't pay attention.
Yeah. So trap artist is just a such
a, such a, so it's a crazy situation.
It's a company where
their clients are mixed.
Some of their clients are a
powerful government agencies.
And I think even the u s military uses
this software at army bases and this is
all legal. Well, I personally don't
think it's legal. I think it just hasn't.
It's something that nobody would have
known about had it not been for wikileaks
and the hacker who allegedly brought
these emails out is now riding in a jail
right now.
Now,
this whole wikileaks situation about
him being in the Ecuador embassy,
how crazy is that? That is completely
crazy that this is our big right now,
this is the US government's one of our
biggest priorities is this dude and this
dude,
by the way,
they're trying to get him out under this
most ridiculous charge of surprise sex.
Right? That's what it is. What it, what it
is is he had sex with a woman and I
guess the alleged story is that he did it
with a condom on and then they were lying
in bed together with no condom and he
stuck it in again and it's,
it's craziness. Well craziness.
If they're willing to like,
that's the going after this guy,
a woman that he actually had said,
yeah, it was a douchebag move. I mean,
if she wanted to wear a
condom and you didn't,
I mean that's a douchebag move for sure,
but you're going to have this gigantic
manhunt for him where he has to hold
himself up in a fucking embassy and to,
to avoid extradition to this country for,
and it just so happens that he's the guy
that releases all this information that
shows helicopters gunning people
down the street, mistaken them for,
for terrorists.
Yeah. Well the thing with wikileaks, uh,
when they reveal stuff that
potentially compromises, uh,
informants and gets
innocent people killed,
I haven't seen a single instance
of that actually happening,
but that argument has been made. And
when that is done, I'm not okay with it.
That is wrong to put innocent
people in harm's way.
You're releasing information that
should not be in the public eye,
but it's advocate to note that you've
done that. Right. But that's the thing.
He has not done that as far as I know.
Uh,
in terms of releasing that video of
innocent people being gunned down and
children being shot full
of lead, uh, that video.
And then this thing about trap wire,
I think these are things that are
in the public interest very much so.
I like to know that all of these new
surveillance cameras going up in towns and
cities because there are a lot of them
now that we're not there a couple of
years ago that many of these could be
plugged into trap wire that's useful
public information. That's what the media
used to do. And a previous generation,
it would be like Walter Cronkite or
Edward Murrow telling you about this.
It would not be Julian
Assange on his little, on his
wikileaks form, you know. So,
uh, I think in some regards what he's
doing is at the forefront of journalism.
And it's funny you brought up the specific
charge that Sweden is trying to get
them on a,
because I've said stuff on Twitter before.
I've said like what I just said no
about how, I think that's journalism.
You put something out there
that's tremendously important
to the public and that
is being covered up and not known.
That's journalism. And somebody said,
why are you defending a rapist like
Julian Assange? And I said, first of all,
that's not even the charge.
He's not being charged with rape.
So get your facts straight.
And second of all,
since when does a alleging
that somebody did something,
that means they're automatically guilty.
It doesn't matter that there's, you know,
tremendous pressure being placed on
them to nail this guy on something.
It's so transparent. It's so big. It
was so obvious that it's something else.
And then going after him from that
wall in Sweden is weird. Like,
I don't think there's an analog of that
in the u s it'd be like, uh, it just,
it doesn't make sense.
It's not right. It's not what did
it, it's craziness that there,
if the race did so much resources to
try to drag him out of the country like
this, it's terrifying. Yeah. Yeah.
Well they're doing it.
To make an example and then talking
about storming the Ecuadorian embassy,
you make an example out of him.
Nobody else is going to have the balls
to create a wiki leaks too. It's done.
Isn't that an act of war?
If they enjoy it and it ends
the whole diplomatic system,
the whole system of embassies, which
is pretty important stuff. Otherwise,
if we don't have that,
then we're just a bunch of animals,
just different countries battling
for resources at all times.
And you have no ground rules. I mean
an embassy is a pretty sacred thing.
So disturbing. And so
part of our reality, man,
I can only hope that with guys like you
running for Congress and with this young
generation that's coming up,
and this is one of the things that I've
said is that I don't think you're going
to change these creepy old vampire
dudes that are running banks.
I think they are fucking set in their
ways and they're a bunch of old douchebags
and our only hope is the upcoming
generation. Guys like you, it's time for,
it's time for everybody to step up who
wants to these mid twenties motherfuckers
with uh, uh, uh, a dedication to change.
And uh, so thanks for doing
what you're doing, man.
And anytime you wanna come on the podcast,
we'd be more than happy to. Thanks.
Having me on is an awesome show.
I'm not just saying that.
It's like the only place where you can
talk about stuff like this for hours.
I go about to explode from the, from
the urine and my bladder. But uh,
that's great.
Like nothing else does that.
Like you get right into
something important,
then they cut you off and that's it
because everybody's so add that that's all
you get.
Well,
I think that we've been tricked into
thinking that that's the only way people
will pay attention.
That you have to give them this little
quick sound bites and then quit.
We is Kim Kardashians getting up and
asked. It's too big. You'll be the judge.
We'll be right back. Yeah, we, we were
so like we were so like distracted.
But there's a lot of people that are
realizing that podcasts and things like
this, these conversations, it's,
it's an opportunity to get a really be
involved really in your own ear buds,
you know, to, to be considering both
sides and, and maybe your own opinion.
It doesn't even get expressed that you
want to express to me on Twitter later or
whatever.
But to be a part of a conversation
between two people talking about something
that you think is really important or
you think is really interesting and that
didn't exist before because we had too
many fucking people that were telling
people what isn't. It is an interesting,
instead of just doing it naturally, right?
So anytime you want to come back on it,
man, we'd be more than happy. All right.
It sounds out. Sounds awesome.
Florida. Respect David
Seaman and the fucking house.
How can they vote for you? When, when,
where are you out of? I am in Florida.
His 20th district. It's in Fort Lauderdale
and parts of Broward and Miami Dade.
But most of your listeners aren't there.
Uh, what we really need is money. Uh,
anybody who's a u s citizen, regardless
of where you live, what state you're in,
if you're a US citizen or legal
permanent resident, you can donate.
It's a David Seaman for congress.com.
And You promise no diamond teeth.
You're not going to use this money
for bitches. No diamond teeth, not,
not too much for strip clubs
or like Eliot Spitzer, hookers.
It's going to be above board.
Beautiful. We support you, dude.
Thank you very much for coming on and
we'll do this again. This is a lot of fun.
We,
I think we barely scratched the surface.
We're trying to help you people in power.
Don't go chasing him and
fucking tapping his phone line.
Just chill. Get your own shit together,
bitch. It's you. It's you running shit.
Afraid of this young lion coming to
shelve everybody. What the fuck is up?
This is, if this is war of Thrones, he'd
be the Goddamn hero game of Thrones,
whatever.
You know what I'm talking about?
Good night everybody.
We'll see you soon.
Thanks to [inaudible] dot
com go to o n n I t.com.
Use the code name Rogan and save yourself
10% off some bad ass brain supplements
and thank you to Alienware. I'm please
follow them on Twitter. Alienware MMA.
Alright, you dirty bitches. We'll see
you tomorrow with immortal technique.
Tee Shirts for sale. Oh yeah.
Powerful new t shirts. New Jess.
What t shirts at Brian has had one here,
right below the ground.
This is a new one. You can buy
it where a desk squad. Dot TV.
Click on desk squad store limited a
death squad. Dot TV quick on Desk Plaza.
Hopefully folks this week we'll uh,
we'll have the least side on a new place
and I'll keep you guys updated on the,
the studio that we're going to put
together there and let bitches know.
All right.
We love you guys and we'll see you soon.
Thanks for all the positive energy and
the tweets and the Facebook messages.
And I've been on Google plus lately.
Yeah, you guys are the shit. I really,
I really, uh, appreciate that we have,
uh, developed this very positive, helpful,
cool community,
very unusually cool community and don't
think that we don't appreciate the fuck
out of it. Brian, I think I can speak
for you as well, right? Yeah. Thank you.
Desk squad, Ohio, all the people that came
up, like 30 people came out, you know,
just huge fans and just beautiful. Just
love us. Yeah. Thank you to everybody.
And we'll see you this weekend if
you're a, if you're in Pasadena. Yeah,
Friday and Saturday night.
Duncan Trussell is not coming
because he's scared of Brian,
but we're going to try to work that
out. All right. We love you guys.
See You tomorrow.